let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
welcome everybody this is the tony
michaels and this is gabe sanchez and we
put together the best of the week from
the tony michaels podcast don't go
anywhere stay right here for the best of
the week
welcome welcome welcome to today's
special coverage of the january 6
select public hearings we have a special
hearing for you today it was announced
yesterday um very very very abruptly
that there would be a
hearing today we didn't we didn't think
that we would actually have one of these
hearings until sometime in july
something has happened with evidence and
this witness that we will talk rc talk
today a cassidy hutchinson an aide to
the former white house chief of staff
mark meadows she would be with mark
meadows uh in most of his duties right
next to him taking notes
using um the calendar to schedule
meetings with him and
for some reason we see new evidence uh
as one of the reasons why the january
six select committee has has chosen to
give us this urgent hearing that we were
going to see today um a lot of
speculation about that some have said
that uh cassidy hutchinson has changed
attorney switched attorneys also has
testified again to the select committee
within the last 10 days some of the
reports coming out about that i'm also
also that there is threats on her um and
we're going to get to the bottom of this
with our commentary today so welcome my
name is tony michaels i am the host here
of today's especial hearing of the
january 6th select committee uh today is
is going to be a bombshell i think i
want to bring in my first guest to talk
about um switching lawyers and why this
all seems
important or why it should seem
important let me go to michael popock uh
one of the hosts of legal af
uh michael how are you today i'm doing
great tony how are you doing oh i'm
doing fantastic tell tell me what you
think about um this situation where she
has switched attorneys do you think that
makes a big difference where she
switched attorneys in the last few weeks
i mean
it seems like it seems like she has
testified within the last 10 days gave
an additional testimony on whatever new
evidence that they found what's your
what's your thoughts on that well let me
frame it for people that are just
joining
and then we'll get to the change in
council which i do believe
um had an impact on her now cooperating
uh closely with the gen six committee
cassidy hutchinson is the proverbial fly
on the wall that we'd all like to be on
the west wing she was not only mark
meadows last
executive assistant she was the chief of
staff meaning she was in every room that
he was in she arranged every meeting and
call that he was involved with
and particularly reporting has come out
that in the last 30 days including in
the last week she's given testimony
about the following events that she
watched mark meadows her boss burn
papers
which are
uh papers that needed to be preserved
for record keeping in the national
archives in his fireplace in his office
and especially after he met
with um a
congressman to discuss uh representative
scott representative scott perry to
discuss
jeff clark being elevated to attorney
general she also was involved with
arranging the trip and accompanying
meadows in december to georgia meadows
was the advanced team for the
attempted corruption of the georgia
election by the trump administration he
went first in december
last minute to meet with cobb county
officials she was with him she arranged
that meeting and this was all the lead
up to the famous infamous january second
phone call involving trump so she was
there for that as a historical figure
she's also testified that she watched
and listened to trump in the dining room
of the of the um of the oval office off
the oval office with her boss mark
meadows in which mark meadows talked
about the chanting at the riot of the
jan 6 insurrection to hang mike pence
and him basically trump saying basically
that's a good idea so she heard that now
to the twitter verse that says or to
congress people that don't like her
testimony that says well she did really
uh she's not a good witness for this
because it's hearsay it's not there's a
hearsay exception if you overhear
somebody plotting a crime that is what
we call an admission against interest
that is a non-hearsay statement she's
completely qualified having heard it to
testify about it the reason why this is
happening i think today is is uh several
fold one she had a
always trumper as her lawyer until about
a month ago she then retained a very
confident and well-respected lawyer
his name is joseph hunt he goes by jody
jody hunt at austin and byrd a very
conservative law firm i know them well
in the white collar department what's
his link to all of this he was jeff
sessions
chief of staff so he knows what it means
to be a chief of staff we all know jeff
sessions was no big fan of donald trump
um and was eventually exited from the
department of justice by donald trump
and he was also a jody hunt was also the
chief of the civil rights division for
two years under under trump he's a
quality guy he is a
sober and mature individual and i am
sure he convinced his client that the
best strategy for her especially with
the georgia grand jury out there was to
cooperate cooperate cooperate with the
gen 6 committee and i think now
jody in combination with the committee
has decided that she's in harm's way
because she is such a critical witness
having given this testimony they need to
take her off the street they need to
bring her in she's now willing under
jody hunt's guidance to give live
testimony which is much more powerful
than clips upon clips upon clips of her
previous 40 hours of testimony and
that's the reason they're doing it but
that's not the only thing that's going
on today i don't think i think they're
going to couple it with the
documentarian footage
which they've been pouring over over the
last 30 days
from alex holder the british
documentarian who has 11 hours of video
of not only the trumps the kids
in jan 5 jan 6 and gen 7 but way back on
september 29th before the first debate
with biden why does that matter because
bannon
and the trumpers
were already conspiring on tape on
record as not going to respect the
outcome of the election to call it a
fraud and to throw it to the house in
september and and i think we're going to
see some video clip from that as well
but even if we only see cassidy
hutchinson as a preview for the early
july hearings i think the reason is
changing council gotta get her off the
street powerful testimony before the
fourth of july break
i i i tend to agree about the footage
part now i'm not sure exactly if we'll
see footage today but
some of the clips that we have um
you know been released um out there in
the space one with trump um one with
pence one with ivanka trump it seems
that maybe they will use her
to corroborate what is happening inside
that footage that we may view today um
as as sidebars like was this happening
here was this happening here we see this
here so i you know she is
supposedly
a very close aid to mark meadows so she
would be standing with him in proximity
of him and
the number one aide she was chief of
staff and his his right hand right so so
when when these conversations are
happening in the room with donald trump
and mark meadows about the election um
she is right there with them
listening to their every word and as we
know in politics in washington and
really any state house the aides
sometimes know more than the actual
official themselves just because um they
see all the background stuff not just
the foreground with the official or the
elected official or appointed official
um they they
to your point to your point john dean he
of white house fame and infamy who went
to jail as white house counsel but has
now rehabilitated himself as a political
commentator he made a good point on his
twitter feed yesterday that said the
only time there was an emergency hearing
a surprise witness at watergate was to
have one of the aides come forward with
the bombshell that nixon was recording
audio
24 7 in the white house we all know that
now but there was actually a witness who
came forward in an emergency hearing
just like that to talk about it i think
that
potentially cassidy hutchinson could be
just as powerful especially if it's
combined with the secret footage of the
documentarian that no one's ever seen
before
i i think i think i think that's a good
analysis of where they're going with
this also i think the reason why this is
so urgent is because there's
been reports that there are a lot of
threats on her life um there seems to be
even more security um today at some of
these hearings i guess that's some of
the reports that there's even heavier
security now
because of this witness and
i i don't believe it's because of
her it's because of what she knows and
what she can testify to
is what they're terrified of and i think
that's why the security is ramped up i
think that's why they wanted to rush her
to get her testimony before she changes
her mind or someone else were to change
her mind um do you think witness
tampering's gonna come into this at all
no i think she's made the decision that
um having switched lawyers back to the
switch of the lawyers having gone with
with jody hunt
she has made the decision that it is in
her best interest
and she's in a perilous position because
she could be um
prosecuted a part of the grand jury in
georgia for whatever her role was in
setting up those things or at least
being a witness to all of it she is
trying to get herself out of harm's way
i don't believe that she's she's she's
succumbing to
trump acolytes calling her tweeting
against her but there are crazies that
are on the fringes of the right wing
that i'm sure having learned because
it's been public in the last four months
in last month that she's given at least
four depositions and little there have
been clips already released by the gen 6
committee so anybody like the midas
mighty that are following this thing
closely on the right wing know that she
you know in their view stepped out of
bounds that is going against uh you know
their cult leader donald trump so i'm
sure she has gotten a fair amount of
terrible
terrible
violent sexually violent things in
addition sent to her that have concerned
her i think that's only going me i think
that's only going to make her
more courageous to step forward and do
the right thing and say what she saw
she's all she's a witness she you know
hopefully she didn't do many of the bad
things that we've talked about already
well i i appreciate your commentary pop
as always thank you for joining us um
and speaking of switching lawyers
because i think that's a big deal i'm
going to switch to another lawyer here
um your co-host ben mizel so thank you
popock for for joining us thank you very
much uh
ben ben i want to bring you in here uh
ben how are you
i'm doing good i guess pop didn't get
the dress code memo huh not well no this
is
oh he's on vacation i guess but but you
know we we are we are we are giving
commentary here so what what do you make
of this what do you make of this uh ben
about the switching lawyers and the rush
the rush to
to a hearing here because
it really was yesterday uh everyone was
playing committee clue it seemed like on
twitter and online who is it who's it
going to be is it going to be this
person is going to be that person and
then we find out that it is a aid to the
former chief of staff mark meadows and
some people kind of felt like at first
womp womp womp but as we start to dig in
um and as we start to look at who she is
what she would know and then the events
that's happened over the last few weeks
we begin it becomes more clear why she
may know some things that they're scared
of what do you make of all the switch
and the urgency to rush to this hearing
well she definitely knows some things um
but what is frightening here
um is that it's obvious her life is
being threatened as the january 6th
committee has
increasingly proven to be successful um
has been exposing trump trump is a maga
for the fascist cult that it is
the same tactics that lead to mob
violence
on january 6 that same mentality when
all the other tricks
and chicanery fail you threaten people's
lives that's what cults do that's what
magga does because it is a despicable
disgusting fascist movement that people
need to take seriously and the media
needs to stop both sides
and we need to focus far less on whether
rudy giuliani was tapped on the back
which the media has called an assault
which is complete [ __ ] and we should
focus on the fact that fascism is
creeping into our country and so what
today is about in my view is that there
is a legitimate fear
that her life is on the line and they
need her testimony immediately and i
know that sounds chilling and that may
sound frightening to those listening but
that we know from prior testimony the
threats to people's lives that are
taking place so that's one of the
reasons with this specific witness who
has michael popock explained the
previous guest before me she switched
lawyers from a maga cult
lawyer to a lawyer who by the way the
lawyer that now represents her
by all means is what traditionally was
viewed as a conservative lawyer it's not
a liberal lawyer or a left-leaning
lawyer even though to me and those who
watch the midas touch podcast to me the
term conservative has completely lost
all meaning because of magga but she's
represented by a credible individual who
doesn't want our country to be overtaken
by fascism and i think we're gonna see
two things you know today we're gonna
see her compelling testimony because
through her as michael popock said she's
a real fly on the wall
she was at every
single
mark meadows meeting
and she was the one taking notes for
mark meadows as his senior aide in every
meeting you know people on capitol hill
who i've talked to say that mark meadows
would refuse to be at a meeting in fact
without cassidy hutchinson present at
the meeting and taking notes for him
cassidy hutchins background by the way
she interned for ted cruz she interned
for other let me try to see who else she
uh interned for so i can get you um some
additional info about her steve scalise
so this is no uh this is no liberal uh
person um so
her testimony is gonna be incredibly
credible everyone who knows cassidy
hutchinson who i've spoken to say that
she worked hard she took notes you know
at the end of the day she was not going
to break the law
which is why you're going to hear
credible testimony and here we really
have someone
i mean isn't it just so interesting that
cassidy hutchinson while all of these
fascist mega men
you know from
uh mark meadows you know to
uh
kevin mccarthy to all these you know
people who are involved are so chicken
[ __ ] to tell the truth you know and here
we have truly the epitome of democracy
the epitome of strength at cassidy
hutchinson so i'm excited to hear a
testimony and i think we're going to see
the video uh clips as well interspersed
so what the gen six committee's done an
incredible job at is telling the story
telling this narration you know and
keeping the audience's interest so we're
gonna get really embedded in these
meetings
through her narrative and then i think
we're gonna see the clips that the john
6 committee has obtained you know that's
something i took away from the last
hearing
that was a planned hearing but it was
the one that was postponed is the
narrative in the story that the
witnesses told about the meeting
where donald trump was trying to get
jeffrey clark to be the ag right and may
and i think you're right that that
this hearing is going to tell that story
of these meetings that we know have
happened we've heard these happening but
really i think the most obvious
time period is what was happening during
the siege on the capitol and she knows
that because she was there she was right
there in the mix with
trump and meadows and i think that's the
aim here to get to trump's intent
um
because
if we know
from someone who was standing there what
his intent was i believe that's gonna
get to the heart of it i agree with you
and look i think trump's intent in terms
of how
uh federal prosecutors would view intent
like federal prosecutors have prosecuted
people with
far less evidence than what we have now
with donald trump but because it's a
very unique situation where you have
and i always hate to even call him a
president but a former president who
still has a substantial following of 25
to 30 percent of the united states are
mega cult members who haven't been
deprogrammed you need to have
the kind of
the normal standards of criminal
prosecution of having uh beyond a
reasonable doubt evidence the standard
has to be like beyond a reasonable doubt
times 10 i think is what the jan 6
committee is trying to show merrick
garland here
because they while there shouldn't be
political considerations you know i of
course inevitably it's a very unique
situation where you have you know a
president that's uh
engaged in a coup in search of legal
theories as a federal district court
judge in california said so there's a
very unique situation but you know i
think today we're going to hear some
powerful bombshell testimony i think
today is going to be the most memorable
day yet ben i want to bring in someone
who's actually um
worked against trump in the courts um
and she's beat him in the courts with
some of his uh ndas and she's still
working hard to beat him i want to i
want to bring in jessica denson here um
jessica what do you make of of
this this i i just want to say it this
woman out front
and here we are
we we had women um that testified before
but not not a woman inside the circle of
trump yet this is the first woman inside
the circle of trump and it appears that
uh she's going to drop bombs
um on trump and the truth really what do
you make of her testimony and the
urgency
having having know how this
the trump circle kind of works
yeah um i i'm going to get back to your
answer and i want to pick up on two
threads that ben mentioned the first is
obviously what we left off off with last
week were these very powerful hearings
and then that momentum as we all know
got truncated by this horrific news from
the supreme court
and i just want to whether it is sheer
coincidence whether it is the the fact
of these witnesses needing to come
forward right now in this new
information or just the dexterity and
talent of this committee i really want
to commend them
for keeping this
narrative of trump's
transgressions top of mind for the
american public because we have we have
a fascist threat on two fronts we have a
fascist threat in our elected officials
that are have created this illegitimate
supreme court and are forcing these
draconian policies on the american
people pushing us back
decades if not centuries and then we
have the threat of impunity for fascists
impunity for wannabe dictators and
neither one of them is any less
threatening to our future as a free
people so i am so grateful to be here
with you today talking about this
january 6 committee in what was supposed
to be a break what is presumably a
holiday or the beginning of a holiday
for many i'm so grateful that we are
focused again on this urgent threat to
our future as a free world
on that thread of women i think it's
another beautiful coincidence i mean
here we are again
just last week we had these two
extraordinary brave women coming forward
sharing their
very personal experiences real
experiences of being threatened by this
fascism threatened by these lies and
this
terrorism of this former president
followed up by this assault on women's
rights assault on women's autonomy on
women's very identity as a human being
and not not as some property for man in
society and then we come forward into
this week with as you said tony the
first woman in this trump orbit in the
trump orbit to come forward for a live
in-person testimony and i do not think
that is a coincidence i think it's
um
it's very telling about
um you know i love men but
women let's just be honest are the
highest species and there's something
about women that has that
about women that that enables us to have
that quality to come forward whether it
is to admit that we were wrong or to
have that courage to confront evil and
so um i'm i'm really interested to see
what this young woman and think about
this this is a very young woman she she
did have a pretty high up position in
the trump administration but as ben was
saying she was an intern before this in
in in office she did not um i think
she's in her mid-20s at best so this is
this is a lot of weight on her a lot of
pressure on her when i came forward i'm
a very independent person and i know
that i know that what i did is not
something that most people
feel the freedom and the independence in
the context of their careers and you
know other social and political
pressures to do i understand that and
this woman with all of those
considerations that you know her future
her career is the first woman from
inside the trump orbit as you were
saying with all of these other men
refusing to come forward to step foot
live into that hearing room and tell the
american people what she knows nothing
to lose sight of i think i think i think
you're absolutely correct and and the
thing i think you're correct about is
that women are way better than men
that's what i i think that's that's the
part you're absolutely correct about ben
what do you make of this being the very
first and i i know it's it it seems like
it may be obvious but i think it's
important that this is the very first
woman inside the trump orbit because
we we saw the election worker and her
mother and in the testimony about the
grandmother in those those women's
testimony uh in front of the the select
committee but they weren't inside the
trump orbit they were the victim of the
people inside the trump orbit but now we
see the first the first woman stepping
forward in the hearing and being
questioned and giving her testimony um
what do you make of that do you think
that's significant i think it's
significant but i think it's obvious the
men in the trump orbit are chicken [ __ ]
that whole fascism that they have is all
whining and playing the victim and
that's what we see repeatedly with trump
they're coming after me
no this is about democracy at the end of
the day this is not a partisan issue and
so it doesn't surprise me that it is a
woman who happened to be in the trump
orbit just because she interned and she
was pursuing a career that led her to be
in that place but who saw it
and called it out the same way jessica
called it out it's not it's not a
surprise that the common strain here is
that it's women who are calling it out
these trump men are not real men these
are disgusting people who try to project
the machismo but they're really pieces
of [ __ ] and i created this media company
midas media network so i can say stuff
like that that you can't necessarily say
on cnn or on the other networks but
that's what we talk about here that's
why they have the trump flags with the
six-pack you know where he's got the
six-pack abs because they want to make
themselves feel like men because they
are the lowest form of
of freaking people these are traitors to
the country and we're going to see a
powerful woman stand up for our
democracy today well i i'm excited
to to
get to her testimony i i'm very excited
to hear exactly what she has to say um
but i think
more than anything she's going to be
very believable
jessica you've you've watched as some of
her testimony in tapes behind closed
doors has been played in some of these
hearings already i i think she's very
believable she's very authentic
you see her sitting on the couch in some
of those clips
and she's just like the last week when
she was talking about the pardons she
was going on and and the best part was
is her authenticity towards marjorie
taylor green like no i didn't really
want to talk to her much anyways i think
she's going to come off as authentic
just seeing what we've what we've
noticed in the clips what's your what's
your take on
if she's gonna i think most women do
come off as authentic um but what what
do you think uh will be the auntie
um yeah yeah i mean i from my very
limited read i i do not know her um she
seems like i think the most
obvious thing about cassidy hutchinson
is you're going to be able to tell she
has no agenda she is just as you were as
we were describing her she is the one
who was in the room um it's just it's
going to be just a very direct testimony
that is unfiltered and untainted um and
yeah i i am
i think that's what that's what we can
expect
awesome well thank you thank you both
thank you ben for sticking around with
jessica and jessica thank you for
joining us and giving us the insight not
just from a woman's perspective but from
a perspective that has fought the trump
uh orbit and is it just me or ben get
some color in texas uh he must have he
must have been out there walking walking
them streets knocking on doors gave him
some some sun there
do you have a rebuttal
i want to say this yeah i did get some
color but see that's one of the benefits
that you get to all the people watching
this right now you gotta walk the walk
as well in addition to talk to talk you
know i flew down to dallas i was
knocking on doors for beto and i
encourage everybody to get involved
whether it's writing postcards knocking
on doors spreading the midas touch
videos and everybody make sure you're
subscribed to the midas touch youtube
channel now we're the fastest growing
independent media company in the world
and we're unapologetically pro-democracy
so subscribe now and make sure you get
out there and get out the message to all
your friends and family also i can't i
can't forget your your brother jordy is
uh making me do a commercial here for
the 10 off the convict or convict 45
enamel pens union made in the usa go to
store.minustouch.com promo code justice
jordy only has a few of these things
left over there so get them why while
supplies last just go to
store.minustouch.com use the promo code
justice for 10 off all merch go over
there and get a convict 45 or convict 45
whichever way you look at it
grab grab your union made in ammo pen
thank you jessica and thank you ben for
joining us uh speaking of texas i'm
going to go to texas paul here
um we got texas paul on the line i think
he's ready here he was having a little
bit of audio issues earlier but i think
he's good now texas paul how are you
i'm doing great how do i say oh you
sound fantastic you sound fantastic it's
a it's uh it's great to see you i know
ben was just talking about your home
state and betto and getting out and
working hard uh to knock the doors you
were at some of these events um if
people go to some of these pictures that
the midas mighty have been posting i can
see the cowboy hat and several of them
so let's let's first start off i i want
to i want to say thank you to the midas
mighty and thank you to you for showing
up and getting out there and
participating uh just as ben said it's
very important that we participate in
our democracy not just talk about it so
those are the most wonderful people i
got to spend three four hours with them
after they had been out block walking
all day and and i i i was driving uh
trying to get there um i live
you know texas everything's hours away
from everything and
they had been out block walking all day
in you know 100 degree heat
and got together and we're the liveliest
most wonderful people i got to meet some
of the best people i swear to god it was
more fun than a barrel of monkeys man
i'm telling you it really was i mean and
and you talk about
dedicated and fired up and and and ready
to go i mean everybody was just like i
mean it was there was no
working for conversation man they were
just chatter boxes you know
we're doing this and we're doing that
and the next event is on this day and
then oh my god
all the pictures they were posting i
think they said they knocked on like
1100 doors and they wrote 200 letters i
mean that that that that's a lot of
people to touch and if everyone does
their part out there and and it you know
really uses their talent i think we can
we can really um touch as many people as
possible and engage in our democracy
speaking of engaging in our democracy um
paul i think that's what we're going to
see today from this witness she's
engaging in her democracy she saw what
was happening she knows exactly what was
said about our democracy and how these
people were trying to tear it down and i
think today we're going to hear her
really torch these folks um give it to
us in your words though i know everyone
loves the texas paul touch here tell us
what you think this witness is going to
do to these moglodites today
well you know first i'm going to start
with mark meadows mark meadows is the
biggest piece of [ __ ] there is on the
planet you know hillary clinton sat
under oath for 11 hours
answered every question mark meadows is
throwing cassidy uh hudson under the bus
i mean just throwing her right under the
bus he knows damn well what manga is
going to do to her
he knows that she has been loyal she's
she's my she has been straight up i mean
look at that she worked for ted cruz she
worked for this is not a left winger
here folks this is somebody that grew up
in the conservative movement
you know was her dream to work in this
white house and they are throwing her
under the bus because they are weakling
sorry pieces of garbage and there's just
no other way to put it she is going and
she's going to sit there under oath
she's got a good lawyer she's going to
tell
everything that happened
and mark meadows could have done this
mark meadows could have spared her this
100 percent
you know she she would have not had the
death threats she her family wouldn't
have to put up the death threats i mean
they're going to make her like living
hell because mark meadows is the biggest
i won't use the p word because the
ladies get mad at me but you know
exactly what i'm thinking
well i i think i think um the word that
they used that trump called pence was
wimp i think that's what you're what
you're getting yeah we'll go with win
not strong enough but we'll go with it
right right i i i appreciate the uh the
strong language you know i i like to use
uh strong language and i think we are
going to see today her testify to the
strong language of these morons in this
room during the siege on the capitol of
what their language was we already know
that
there's reports of her witnessing trump
cheering that they were
talking about hanging and i'm talking
about
the army of of morons that he
you know
sent to our capital to take away our
democracy i believe that
um you're going to see her describe in a
lot of words
exactly how the president united states
was cheering that his supporters
were chanting hangmite pence uh in that
moment because he was terrified that
mike pence wouldn't do what he wanted
him to do which he knew was illegal
everyone knew was illegal i mean even
even last the last hearing we
we heard from uh rosen and donahue the
acting attorney general and deputy
attorney general who was in the room
steven engel even who was in the room as
donald trump was trying his damndest to
find anyone even if he had to make
jeffrey clark this buffoon the attorney
general um but i think we're gonna hear
more about those meetings today and what
the details were and i don't think she's
going to hold back at all uh she may
just go all texas paul on the hearing
room today i don't know she is going to
tell us
everything she was in the room for
i would probably guess 98 of the
meetings that they had
and you know because it's it's it's a
well-known
you know fact that
mark meadows did not want to step into a
meeting without her being there she was
his memory his his hit i mean his record
she's gonna sit down and she's gonna
tell it all and that's why i have to
tell you it pisses me off so damn bad we
democrats don't do this we don't throw
our freaking staff under the bus we
stand up and say we did this and we
believed we we did this because we
believed it was the right thing to do if
you're sitting there declaring the fifth
freaking amendment or trying to hide
behind hide behind presidential
privilege does not exist in a crime
there's no such thing as presidential
privilege in the commission of a crime
so mark meadows is sitting there like
the biggest piece of [ __ ] that he is and
throwing cassidy hutchinson under the
bus because he's too damn scared
to face the maga freaks that are out
there that i mean bottom line that is it
there is no other reason he could
possibly give because he's not spared
from incrimination
everything hutchinson said is what he is
going to say
there is no reason other than he is a
complete and utter
coward
well i appreciate your commentary uh
paul and and i i know everyone
appreciates that you don't hold back uh
thank you for joining us here today
stick around because i know you you'll
be able to give commentary hopefully in
the middle if we have a break and then
at the very end now thank you texas paul
yes can i have one thing um yes go ahead
mine the mighty mighty down
in that gathering it came out that the
midas mighty down here in texas have
knocked on any door on more doors for
beto than any other organization out
there getting help they have knocked on
more doors than anyone else they are bad
ass to the extreme and i tell you what
tony yes we're not that far you need to
come down and party with these people oh
okay they are fun people man i'm telling
you all day long out 100 degree heat
they got together and man we were
you just got to ask ben about it it was
a blast and jordy jordy had a good time
i appreciate i appreciate everyone down
there in texas working hard to save our
democracy um i want to go to another
midas money thank you paul for joining
us i want to go to another midas mighty
favorite a karen agnipolo from legal af
um karen uh how are you today let's see
let's get there we go hey karen how are
you
hi i'm good how are you i'm i'm doing
fantastic what do you make of this
witness and all the drama that has led
up to this in the last you know 16 hours
18 hours or so and
i i think
um because i think we even were texting
back and forth like who is this person
who is this witness going to be then
we've again like i told ben earlier we
found out it kind of felt underwhelming
at first but then once you dive into it
and you get into who she is what she
knows and then the circumstances over
the last few weeks
um from a prosecutor's standpoint
because that's really what i want to get
from you from a prosecutor's standpoint
what do you think this means i mean is
this significant that she's coming
forward and the committee is rushing to
hear her testimony in public
yeah so you know i i can't help but i i
can't help but have the song from
hamilton did you watch it do you ever
see hamilton the the broadway show i i i
can't have okay well i can't get the
song out of my head you know she was in
the room where it happened you know
because boy was she in the room where it
happened and that that is sort of who
she is you know michael popock said it
perfectly she's the proverbial fly on
the wall
and so
what was very interesting about this
emergency surprise hearing whatever you
want to call it
is you know i i think there's still
going to be a lot of surprises because
don't forget she has testified already
on what four depositions
so it's not like she hasn't
been before the committee and it's not
like we haven't heard from her from the
committee so what's new what's the
emergency what's the surprise what is
she going to come up with that she
hasn't come up with before or said
before
that's what i think is going to be very
interesting about
today's hearing you know it can't just
be will live testimony is more powerful
than
um
than taped testimony because again they
would have known that already and
planned for that already there's
something has happened
and it could be
that she's had threats that's one
possibility and so she wants to get her
statement out there
now
it also could be that she sees the
writing on the wall which is you know
the department of justice i think is
doing
you know is clearly doing an
investigation and and this sort of
circle is tightening right you know we
we saw the the warrant being
served on john eastman
in that video and we obviously heard
about it in his filing that he
that he filed you know we wouldn't have
known about this about john eastman for
example had he not brought it to our
attention because law enforcement didn't
say anything about it so for all we know
law enforcement is circling in on
mark meadows or cassidy hutchinson or we
just don't know and it's very clear to
me that the department of justice is
watching these hearings
and
ramping up their investigation based on
partly things that are coming out at the
hearing you know because it's they're
not waiting they are
serving subpoenas um they're they're
serving warrants you know the eastman
was a warrant and
i just found that that very interesting
because a lot of white collar
investigations what what the fbi and the
department of justice will sometimes do
is allow
people to um they could have subpoenaed
his phone right and they could have
had let him turn it over but no they did
the surprise we're gonna show up with a
warrant and put your hands on top of
your head and take your phone because
we're worried that you're going to
destroy information and again they are
that means to me they are intensely
intensely investigating this case and
it's heating up and so i think that's
what's coming what what this is related
to i think that that the the the circle
of prosecution is tightening around the
trump inner circle and she has
information and she doesn't want to go
to prison i mean she i think is a true
believer and was a true believer
but not to the point of going
you know going to
going to prison uh for the on their
behalf and i think that's where it's
where it's heading
so let me ask you real quick with one
one more question to that aim is do you
think that um possibly cassidy hudson
thinks hey maybe i have or this new
attorney has said hey you might have
some criminal liability here if you are
not and and maybe protecting herself in
a way of saying hey i i cooperated i
cooperated to the fullest extent if she
would ever see that criminal liability
in accord somewhere do you think that's
part of it or do you just think
um that she doesn't want anything to do
with a criminal prosecution at all
rather she's the the target or a witness
i mean obviously she's going to be a
witness here but what what what what do
you say to that
look nobody wants to be part of criminal
prosecution nobody nobody wants to be a
witness and be cross-examined and go
through that whether you like you know
whether whether
you like the person or just dislike the
person it's it's not a fun experience
i'm sure she doesn't want to but you
know the criminal justice system doesn't
work that way you if you have evidence
in a case and uh they know you have
evidence in a case you have no choice
but to testify of course you can take
the fifth um you know but that's sort of
um you know that that's neither here nor
there i think she
uh
i think she potentially well for sure we
know she's a witness right for sure she
saw people burning you know um
burning you know documents um the whole
you know hang mike pence and trump
saying that's a good idea you know the
chanting i mean you know all of that is
clearly she's a witness right and so she
has information whether she could
potentially be prosecuted herself i
don't know and that'll be interesting to
see
um but i'm like i said i'm just curious
what's the emergency what's the new
information that
required to be called for a new hearing
because they've heard from her at least
four times so something has happened
from the time that she's testified to
today
and it's going and and i don't know what
that is it could be that she's had a
change of heart and you know she
has information that she was scared to
give before or didn't want to give
before and now she does it could be that
the prosecution's heating up and it's
gotten close to her it could be these
threats you know and she's she's just
sort of needs to get her statement out
there it could be that you know she's
had a complete change of heart and she
suddenly wants to do the right thing
i have no idea but something has
happened between then and now and i
think that's going to be what the
bombshell is that at least i'm looking
forward to
to seeing today because it's a pretty
big deal
well thank you karen for joining us i
appreciate it i want to go to the thank
you for joining us as always and if you
can stick around and we'd love to hear
if we get uh time in the middle or at
the end what some of your analysis of
her testimony is thank you karen for
joining us um i want to bring in the
politics of this although because we've
heard from a few attorneys here about
the the legal aspect i want to bring in
some folks that know about the politics
some political strategist here uh david
bender and one of my favorite political
strategists sorry david um dr rachel
biddikover uh thank you thank you for
joining us sorry david i i i i love you
to death but rachel is is my favorite
political strategist she knows she knows
from i'm leaving i'm leaving now
you can do that and but i think
he wins the hat race though well
well well thank you for that and rachel
i defer to you as i understand it uh
this witness was one of your students is
that right
yeah yeah and you know what's
sad is i'm really bad with names so it
never registered to me i follow the
day-to-day on the
on the um you know investigation and so
i knew that i had read you know a
witness cassidy hutchinson had changed
her
legal team away and and divested her
legal representation away from the
so uh but but then it was when we had
the last hearing and they showed the
video and i i was i looked at the screen
and i was like oh oh
that's my student and
that was crashing
it's such an unfortunate thing because
this kid was very she's very bright she
was in my quant class
and um you know she she was obviously
well connected because she told me she
was graduating and going to work on in
steve scalise's office which is of
course you know what that he's he's he
was he's in the republican leadership
that's a very prestigious posting for a
fresh out of college
student so generally speaking when my
better connected students are going off
into trump world i always gave him sage
advice which was you know don't commit
any crimes
[Laughter]
let's let's uh just for the information
and i think uh people didn't know i
didn't know this was you were teaching
christopher newport university
in virginia
and this is where she graduated and
she's very
still very young this is 2018.
yes guys yes i mean i'm so i'm actually
a little glad to like i don't know her i
mean she was a student in my class we
got along i connected and mentored many
young conservatives uh which is kind of
funny because you know the university
pushes me out
um but you know i was i was a good
mentor to the young republicans because
let me tell you
like that's the future if we win
we have to we can't just blow up we must
fix right and so i always like to make
good relationships with my conservative
students and try to steer them a little
bit away from the radicalism that's you
know the other side of youth con the
youth conservative movement the turning
point usa side is radical as [ __ ] you're
the most important person now today in
anyone doing analysis before she speaks
because you know her yeah
and in saying that
here she is doing
she did it for 20 hours and four
depositions she's done the right thing
yeah she stood up against what must be a
tremendous amount of pressure
this is no doubt i'm so glad that you're
saying that because it's coming from
someone else and not just me like i want
people to understand what put yourself
in the shoes of a kid for a shot of out
of out of college right you're 22 23
years old
you're getting you're on this promotion
like um locomotive too because the trump
trump world was weird like that i mean
because nobody really nobody wanted to
go to jail
so they
so like you could move that ladder up
really [ __ ] quick you know
she stayed longer than most i mean
because mark meadows was there for
longer than five minutes she was she was
his right hand yeah for a
long relatively long period of time in
trump world which is more than a week
you guys all see saw her care i don't
have to actually attest to her character
because i think everyone saw it in that
deposition they aired last time when
they asked her about marjorie taylor
green and she the look on her face was
like yeah i don't i don't talk to it
tomorrow i don't talk to her
exactly right we didn't know we didn't
know until
late last night uh and they did do a
close hold and i think
one can reasonably assess that the close
hold is not only because of what she's
going to say
but because the pressure on her if this
was two weeks from now it would be
tremendous not to do it and they'd start
savaging
her reputation yes saying that she you
know all of the things that one can say
to marginalize a witness and
particularly a young woman
believe me they would do it and so
getting her out there quickly makes a
lot of sense they had to bring members
of congress back
from recess i mean adam schiff flying
cross country who was cheney flying
cross country
there's a reason they did this this
quickly they didn't want to use this
moment
yeah there's some i mean it's got to be
good
that's what i figured
you know i mean the committee
if the committee had been run
differently and like it was run in so
many ways our democratic stuff is run
without like a media strategy that
that's not the case here there's been a
very competent very effective media
comms component of this and so you just
know the committee understands
expectations
you know and uh they knew that to call
an emergency session 24 hours away not
later in the week but right away was
going to raise expectations both about
who the witness was all right and i
think it was good to get out who it was
because expectations on that the
speculation was causing expectations to
get even my own expectations to get very
high you know all of us sure
but i think it's important to lower
those expectations and to realize that
what may
be happening here is not so much
anything new
and it's possible
but that if we're thinking about the
reality of this young woman this fresh
out of college essentially she's had
jobs she had scalise then she went to
ted cruz think of think of that
but she was uh
her
her life in the world is really
relatively brief as an adult she's still
a very young woman who is about to go on
the national stage
and you know
what that's going to do and i feel for
her i i really do
it concerns me greatly and i think the
committee
understood there must have been
negotiations uh tell me
rachel
tony if you heard what i heard
in the voice off camera when she's doing
the deposition it's a woman talking i
think it's liz cheney asking her those
questions
i i felt the same way yes i think it was
liz cheney uh off when when they're
talking about the pardons and she's
sitting on the couch it sounded like it
sounded like darth vader jr i mean liz
cheney to me uh you know like i call her
darth vader jr um but i i do i do
believe that it was liz cheney i think
that's very important um and i think
that was sending signals because let's
talk about the politics of this of what
could be the political ramifications of
today because we watched and rachel you
can confirm or deny this for me but the
generic ballot is moving and it seems
like it's moving in the correct
direction for democracy here um it is a
slight movement and it's slow but it
seems like people are finally picking up
on what has happened what these people
tried to do to our democracy and why
it's so important it's so important to
engage and know exactly the facts and
act on those facts tell us about the
politics i'll start with rachel tell me
about the politics of this and what it
means today
in in the political body of the country
i mean we're really a tale of two cities
here we're in a world that's well known
where fundamentals in party and out
party fundamentals predict election
outcomes and when you couple them with
[ __ ] [ __ ] economic indicators
like recession and inflation high gas
yeah you know it's not good right but
we've got these two intervening
variables i mean it takes something
titanic
to be an intervening variable the court
curtailing row would not have been a
good enough it would take a full
evisceration and that's why i know mitch
mcconnell was like damn wish we would
have caught that car
next year not this year right so um you
know we're really talking about we don't
we don't know and and we
we want to see data you referred to the
generic ballot we don't know if that's
moving yet we we think we might see
movement but we don't actually know we
won't know until we look at the
aggregated generics in a few days we
should start to see the movement though
rachel let me stop you did you see
rachel did you see a marist poll that
came out
i saw it yesterday and and i i'd like to
see it it was sent to me and i want to
see if it's accurate it was embarrassed
nbc poll that showed the generic
flipping 12 points
uh
in in terms of
a democratic advantage now of seven
and having been down five in the last
marist poll head-to-head
uh yeah i'm definitely i mean you know
i don't love marist either but still no
i mean it's not even that i mean it's
like i don't love any single indicator
you know what i mean like so like you
know so we'll know i mean we're gonna
know guys and i know we want to know now
because we're americans and we're used
to knowing [ __ ] before it happens right
but the fact is we can't know until the
data gets fielded and collected and
comes from what you're seeing right now
are going to be the online panels the
large
larger panel studies are going to start
to come out
and we just we need to give it a week
and we'll have a better sense of the
data but i don't i try not to look at
any one indicator like that especially
for something we're talking about did
the generic ballot to put this frame of
reference we we started in the fall
talking and bitching about internal
party fighting about buildback better
and sausage making it was just a shitty
media environment and then it switched
to ukraine and and then the gn6 [ __ ] and
the generic ballad has never moved
through any of it nothing until this row
thing if it does move it's predominantly
coming from row that doesn't mean that
the gn6 [ __ ] isn't important it is
because it's going to give us the
ability to take these top line
like you know the the the whole
contextual story and give it a
compelling
you know narration to the to the voting
electorate using this material but at
the end of the day well if we're going
to see stuff it's going to be because of
roe
tell me if you agree with this and tony
and i have been talking about this
offline a good bit
on friday it occurred to me that we
finally have proof of what donald trump
did not just
through january 6th and and trying to
overthrow the constitution he is
undermining the constitution with three
appointments the supreme court that's
his legacy
and
the hashtag that came to me was
trump court
that's what it is now and people like
lawrence tribe and normizen and others
have been putting that forward in the
world but tell me if you agree uh rachel
that that connecting up
the anger that people feel about
this court and not only what it's done
but what it said it's going to do
yeah with all the other cases on the
document 23 24 22 22-23 next year
isn't trump court
the essence of focusing people's anger
on this man not just for january 6 but
for what he is doing to the constitution
and the country yeah i mean it can be
what you'd have to you'd have to check
around like
do some testing on that here's my
problem with trump instead of republican
it's like
they don't
what we want to be doing is they want to
be branding the whole party as trump so
i you know the problem when you when you
rely exclusively on a past president as
your commander
you're giving up some of that power and
where their power is the most
significant against us is that broad
brush it's all of us we're all groomers
there's no such thing as a moderate
democrat they're all
rabid breathing you know
foaming socialists that want to steal
all your [ __ ] right so like if we if we
brand everything trump then trump
becomes a a like a cancerous cell in an
otherwise healthy party and that's not
what we have
in the short term there is a goal here
and there's a goal that we're trying to
create a climate in which
60 plus percent of the country think and
right now it's moving that direction
it's not there yet
think that this man should be indicted
and as i say justice is blind but this
is how justice is blind
justice will hear through her fingers
and merrick garland is the one peering
through those fingers so if he sees that
uh trump is associated not just with
what we're going to see in this
committee
and what we're going to see in the
evidence but what
and people are really genuinely angry
about that that's going to create a
climate in the short term there's a
consequence not even the election in
november
in getting those indictments
and one of the things we've heard so
many times is that
the politics of doing indictments
against this former president will
divide the country
and the argument i make is that if the
country is not divided if it's 60 to 65
in favor of it that makes it a lot
easier
well it doesn't matter ultimately what
what should matter to merrick garland is
this stark and harsh reality life is
brutish nasty and short marriage okay
and here's your two options you can
either
indict a former president and deal with
the political fallout that that is no
doubt going to create or you can just
allow the rule of law to die in america
and allow the constitution to die so
like you know i feel like yeah it's it's
a tough it's a tough decision but the
only thing worse than prosecuting trump
and the rest of the coup plotters is not
doing exactly cannot have a stable
functioning democracy after that so he
really to me
doesn't have a lot of choices and he
seems like a guy that's gonna get that
but i'll never trust anyone again after
robert mueller
fair point and that's again why making
this as
broad-based as possible creating a
popular consensus that this is the right
thing to do that's what the committee's
job is and anything that can be done to
help it that's why i think keeping the
pressure on trump in the short term in
this next three to four months is
crucial long before we get to november
now is the time and and am i correct i'm
seeing people gathering have they have
they started walking yet yes they they
haven't brought the witness and i i
think that there's been a lot of extra
security at the hearing today the report
so
we may be just a few minutes over here
because of some of these uh
it looks like they're photographing now
so it looks like the witness is going to
enter oh nope there's there is there's
yeah
he's he's running late
the select committee will investigate
the january 6th attack
on the united states capitol will be in
order
pursuant to the order of the committee
of today the chair declares the
committee in recess for a period of
approximately 10 minutes
so there you have it the hearing with uh
huge bombshells
here as we
watch the witness cassidy hutchinson
leave the room
with security until
uh benny thompson does not
does not look thrilled about the
evidence that has been presented because
it was a threat to our democracy i want
to bring in our panel i hear clapping in
the room now i want to bring in our
panel real quick because we don't have a
lot of time i want to give everyone a
chance uh so give me just a minute as i
bring in everyone here um we have a big
panel here
everybody holy actual [ __ ] this is [ __ ]
yes um so i wanna i wanna go to uh let's
start at the bottom at rachel
bittikoffer rachel uh if you'll unmute
your mic and tell us exactly what you
what you saw there and um again let's
let's keep it short so everyone has a
chance to speak but go ahead
yeah i'll keep it real short whoo
and i'm very proud of cassidy hutchinson
for coming and telling us the truth
today that i think we're getting the
actual whole truth and nothing but the
truth from her and damn look at this
like trump is a physical
abuser and that's that's just a crazy
spin that i didn't see coming somebody
else go
go ahead go ahead david if you want
yes this reminds me uh and again going
back in in memory to john dean
her her precision the fact that she
remembers every detail and can do it
without looking at notes she can tell
you
where she was that the door was pulled
shut when and they'll be very
interesting to find out who
uh meadows was talking to that she
couldn't hear
while trump was still speaking but the
precision of her testimony reminded me
of john dean
and let's be clear john dean was the
linchpin to bringing down richard nixon
this was an important incredible day
uh karen agnivolo let's go to you um i
know you probably have
a lot of notes there for what you want
to say but give us give us in a quick
synopsis what you thought of some of
this testimony uh the president united
states being i don't know the baby in
chief this is um
this is crazy stuff
yeah so
i still don't understand so i still
don't understand what's new because so
much of what she testified to was also
they would keep going back and forth
between the clips and what was the
emergency makes me wonder was this
planned you know and they sort of so she
couldn't get threat threatened before
but you know a lot of this already had
come out in the clips and was taped but
the real bombshell that i thought was
just sort of how violent the president
is and the fact that he tried to grab
the wheel of his of the the beast and
which is such a weird word anyway for a
car um but they tried to grab the wheel
that he tried to attack
um angle the fact that he
you know throws dishes and and threw a
temper tantrum and tried to you know
throw the throat yeah exactly hi ben you
know the fact that he kind of grabbed
the the tablecloth and you know just to
show that he's sort of a violent dude
and
um he's kind of an out of control guy
you know like like i'm sure he's
horrified to know now that the whole
world knows that he's out of control and
loses control of his crazy baby emotions
so you know so i thought that that was
the big bombshell i think the circ that
she basically threw mark meadows and
rudy giuliani and donald trump under the
bus i i won't be surprised to see those
three people prosecuted i'll i'll turn
it over to to ben micellas
uh ben let's let's go to you i've seen
my time i seed my time i have my ketchup
karen most of that was not known to me i
mean there was in my view revelation
after revelation there i mean she took
us right in the heart of what was going
on on january 6th and the biggest piece
of it was was that
trump viewed himself like a napoleon
conquering and he wanted to
go into the capitol building with the
insurrectionist who he wanted to be
armed with ar-15s and he wanted to
literally you know and as i think what
he's saying that good without hanging
you know vice president pence and
everything his plan in his own sick mind
was to go to the chamber and like
declare himself dictator i mean that's
what we heard today um you know ben let
me ask you a question
can i ask you a question sorry tony i
don't believe your role but i have a
question for ben i agree most of this
wasn't known to any of us right but it
was known to the committee it was on
tape what was the emergency that
happened in the last 24 hours that they
needed to have this live versus do you
think it was just she changed her mind
and was willing to come in live do you
think she had a change of heart that's
my question is so much of what she had
her notes in her notebook and she was
very methodical but a lot of it was was
taped in in the bag for the hearing
people what was it that caused them to
call this hearing an emergency and
present this live that that's my
question that i'd love to hear your take
ben
my take is is that we're in like
halftime right now right so
we've heard some bombshells in halftime
but we don't know you know where the
hearing is going to go in a little bit
we know that there's kind of documentary
evidence supporting it but i would say
we're in recess we're going to go back
and
i'm okay with how they wanted to frame
it they want to call it an emergency
unemerging call whatever the hell you
want it but we exposed donald trump
today and then let's see what happens in
the next you know when we come back from
recess i would just say i don't have a i
don't have a concrete answer for karen
but i've heard some speculation that
there may be this may have been a
balancing act with things that are going
on at the doj
um wanting to either preempt or get this
this testimony out from
prior to something happening at the doj
i have no solid um you know information
but that's speculation that i've heard i
just wanted to add like i mean this
these violent outbursts from donald
trump hearing them in real time like
this i mean it's it is it's just floors
you but let us not forget this is a man
who had credible multiple credible
allegations of rape going back decades
so
we know this is these are his
proclivities and for god's sakes let us
finally hold him accountable this time
uh i want to go to uh the texas paul uh
texas paul what did you think of some of
the bombshells there i mean i don't
think it's surprising that donald trump
is a little whiny baby but the the thing
that struck me and and speak on this if
you would
he really he really like ben said
napoleon um complex here he thought he
was gonna go there he could do whatever
he want even grab a steering wheel and
grab someone by the throat
to get physically violent in that moment
um because he's so pissed off that
they're not letting him be the dictator
he wants to be what did you what do you
think of that paul exactly ben beat me
to it that was exactly my first thought
was that this was his plan he knew these
people were armed he knew they were
armed with ar-15s he knew they were
armed with with with uh handguns he was
going to march them down to the capitol
he was going to walk into the middle of
the capitol and declare himself king
that's exactly what he intended to do
that day and it was being taken away
from him because he could not be there
he saw people responding to this
situation he saw
that's why he would not call it off
because he had every intention of
walking down there and declaring himself
king the other thing that just
completely
just
i have been dying to find out who was
talking to the oath keepers and the
proud boys and and and
facilitating the violence and the fact
that rudy giuliani knew on the second
he knew on that meeting he told he told
i you know i jotted it down here he he
told he told cassidy hutchinson on the
second the proud boys and the oath
keepers were going to be there and and
who was armed
you know
we
oh
this is i mean this is it this this is
it i believe you're absolutely right the
the reason that this was i thought maybe
it was death threats was why that they
had to bump this up so much that she was
getting nervous because of death threats
you know i believe i believe jessica's
absolutely right the you know we've seen
fbi agents moving over the last few days
like what happened with eastman coming
out of the restaurant i believe that
that they are they are moving and they
don't have the patience to wait
for the showmanship anymore so that i
think that they agreed to get this out
there today
get it over with and you watch there
will be fbi agents all
over the damn place over the next few
days
electronic devices but i am so goddamn
man i just
can you believe that arrogant son of a
[ __ ] i mean attacked his own security
throwing dishes and [ __ ] like that
that's not a president well that's not
he's out of control he's out of control
what i tell you
ketchup and broken glass
well i'll tell you i'll tell you that
that um i'm not surprised by it actually
i'm i'm actually i was surprised to hear
it come out of someone's mouth finally
under oath in front of the world but i'm
not surprised that that was the
statement uh gabe does so many videos
and he actually predicts things that he
doesn't even know he predicts because
these people are so easily predicted he
actually had a video that he put out
months and months and months ago and it
had cassidy hutchinson in it
inadvertently even didn't even know it
didn't even know it but but these people
are so easy to predict because they're
so
unpredictably unpredictable if you want
to put it that way donald trump is a
whiny little [ __ ] he's been that way
for a long long long time he will
continue to be that way even if he is in
an orange jumpsuit and leg irons he will
continue to be a whiny little [ __ ] gabe
what do you think about some of the
stuff we i i know you're not surprised i
mean no yeah i mean yeah none of this is
surprising but i mean like the key
details kind of painting the picture of
what happened that day behind the scenes
were like okay what we always were
suspecting actually ended up be true i
mean like the fact that he's throwing
dishes and it's ketchup we know he was
eating fast food we know that after
after the election that people in the
white house had to clear out the odor of
flatulence he was farting everywhere
from eating ben he's binging eating fast
food
that's the kind of guy he's sitting in
the goddamn car having a tantrum because
he wants to go to disney world trying to
take control from his parents being the
secret service and then they say no get
back in the seat we're going back home
and then he starts trying to choke out
the parent which is the secret service
like what world do we live in where the
sitting president of the united states
begins to choke out the person that's
there to protect him
like what what is happening what what
what alternative universe are we in you
can't even write this stuff
what's happening is he wanted to be king
and they were not letting him do it
exactly he knows if he i guarantee you
if donald trump had made his way down to
the capitol with all these armed sons
and [ __ ] and he said it himself
they're not here to hurt me take the
magnetometers away he knew about this
plan very very important observation
they're not there to hurt me well then
who are they there to hurt right and he
knew exactly what it was a couple of
things gabe you got to connect up
something you just said
there's flatulence
why do you think they call it the beast
get into that thing with him of course
it's the beast and by the way i think we
learned something new i could be wrong
this is the first time i've heard his
secret service code name is mogul
i've heard i've heard that before maybe
you know maybe my code name for him
grandpa poopypants now that gabe has
exposed him as a flatulence
the thing that i if if i can suggest one
fact we know
is that recently
uh cassidy hutchinson changed council
she changed counsel from having a trump
friendly counsel to jody hunt who was
chief staff to jeff sessions
jody hunt was the guy in the oval office
who bore witness to trump's reaction
when he was told that mueller had been
appointed yep i believe the exact quote
is jesus i'm [ __ ]
is now
hutchinson
seriously on the point you were making
game this out trump makes it to the
capitol
trump gets into the chamber
game this out what happens because if
they don't finish their work on january
6 we know what starts to happen with the
clock and they had what till the 11th or
something before they went to the boat
it goes to the house after that if they
can't right you're 70 right
but what happens gain this up trump
makes it down i mean let's let's live in
that reality trump reality
hang on a second hang on a second i have
some i have some breaking news here um
donald trump is truthing from his two
central account um here here is the
words that he's he's tweeting uh gabe
can you can you see if you can put
together a graphic so we can pull that
up real quick um we're watching as the
committee's coming back in but i wanna i
want to get to this i hardly know who
this person cassie hutchin is other than
i heard very negative things about her a
total phony and leaker and when she
requested to go for certain others it's
hard to read his writing here of the
team to florida after my hamming served
a full term in office um the committee
is uh working their way back into the
room i apologize to the panel to cut you
guys off but there is breaking news um
donald trump uh gabe maybe you can tweet
that out or um from our account and so
everyone can see that we're going to go
back to the
we're going to go back to the hearing
here
without ejection
the committee stands adjoined
and there you have it the
adjournment of the committee
with bombshell testimony
from the aid of the former white house
chief of staff mark meadows
cassidy hutchinson
um
as chairman benny thompson described it
they're doing her patriotic duty today
i want to bring in someone who
understands donald trump better than
most
because he's been close to
the former president united states he
was his former personal attorney
michael cohen is joining us now
michael i want to get your take on some
of the testimony today uh as we watch to
see
cassidy hutchinson here
um being taking photos as she's leaving
what was some of your take on the
testimony today michael
like everybody else's you're just
sitting there shaking your head uh tony
and saying wow i mean um
from the
throwing of the food against the wall in
the white house
all the way to the attacking of his uh
secret service agent in the beast
you know to the fact that each and every
one of you it appears to me that each
and every one of these gop members knew
exactly what was going to happen in
advance of january 6th insurrection and
yet
they all said nothing they all
they all did absolutely nothing and i
hope that the people that are watching
this program on midas touch live i hope
that they remember this the testimony of
an insider like i was when i testified
in congress an insider who's telling you
that donald trump is a clear and present
danger to the united states of america
but i want to make one more point it's
not just donald it's all of these
enablers i mean you may recall when mark
meadows and jim jordan and matt gates
and a whole slew of others attacked me
the day that i testified before the
house oversight committee and my
response back to them was i know what
you're doing i've been there i know the
playbook you know how i wrote it and i
know that you're going to see the same
headaches that i'm seeing and that might
me and my family are dealing with right
now and lo and behold two years plus
later another thing that i had said is
coming true and i got to be honest with
you what they did
is
it's
it's uh unimaginable i mean there's just
no way to describe or to put into words
the level of
deceit to the american people only
criticism of today's testimony and all
of the testimony by all of these folks
why didn't they come out sooner because
if cassidy's and god bless her and i
really hope she stays safe because it's
great they love to get you up there they
turn around they tell you what you've
done is patriotic to the country but
nobody nobody except for a handful of us
know the danger that donald trump poses
to you and your family once you leave
those halls so i want her to remain safe
but
at the end of the day you have to turn
around and you have to get out there you
got to vote all of these animals out of
office because look what they wanted to
do is what i warned the country also two
years ago as the first person to do it
there will never be a peaceful transfer
of power if donald trump loses the 2020
election well let me ask you because you
you you talk about her safety and we
even um
we've seen statements from witnesses
like hey be loyal be loyal and
everything will be fine nothing you know
nothing will happen to you um this seems
to be a pattern with the trump world and
trump himself is that these thin belts
threats it it almost seems like witness
tampering um
you know adam
what do you mean tony it almost seems
like it is witness tampering it's
witness tampering and obstruction of
justice just look it up in wikipedia and
you'll see exactly the actions that
donald trump and his acolytes do
is witness tampering and obstruction of
justice plain and simple but yet look
we've seen enough testimony from this
hearing we have seen enough information
over the course of the last two plus
years in order to have locked this man
away for a long time but not just him
it's the whole group of them
stunning testimony today exceptionally
important to history but then again it's
just adding another layer to the cake of
the illegalities that donald trump in
his you know and his inner circle are
responsible for over many many years
what did you make of the
um temper tantrum but particularly the
one
in the vehicle in the beast that they
described where he he physically put his
hands on the wheel and physically put
his hands on someone i find it you know
kind of uh i guess hilarious we watched
rudy giuliani get padded on the back and
somehow he was you know suplexed onto
the ground but here we have the
president united states he's so pissed
off that they won't allow him to go to
the capitol to crown be crowned king or
whatever he thought was going to happen
so upset that he was he was willing to
physically put his hands on the person
who was going to protect him what do you
make of that that image yeah i look i've
seen donald trump throw temper tantrums
on a handful of occasions in my book
disloyal i actually uh cite one incident
which was against don jr when don jr
said the wrong thing uh while we were at
the wwe raw uh where there was a schtick
going on with him and vince mcmahon for
the purchase and then the sell back of
the wwe to him uh don said the wrong
thing it was a pretty innocuous
statement uh
that
do you ever get nervous going out in
front of big crowds like this in essence
what don was trying to do is to tell his
dad it's a huge crowd because even back
then
size matters for trump and obviously not
according to stormy daniels but size
matters um you know in trump land and
that set him off to the point you know
that he went ballistic don jr got thrown
out of the room i ended up leaving to go
talk to him you know because he was
obviously upset over his father's
reaction but i've seen other events
where trump starts slamming his hand you
know on the desk and so and you would
think you know that he broke his hand
that's how hard that he hit it but you
know who these actions remind me a lot
of is like the actions of like kim
jong-un um you know when
he behaves in a way which is so
narcissistic and dictatorial that i'm
not shocked at anything that came out of
cassidy's mouth today i'm just
disappointed that this information
didn't find its way to the american
people
months and months and months ago
especially during the second impeachment
so what do you make of maybe the
movement from here on out now that we
have this out in the space i mean it
seems like there's a lot of people who
have criminal liability now just from
the testimony that was uh spoken today
by cassidy one person in particular
would be her former boss mark meadows um
man well you have chippoloni on top of
that you have you know potentially jared
on top of that you also have um you have
jim jordan you can also have thrown into
this whole mix uh you know a handful of
other individuals that were all involved
uh especially the group roger stone
you know who took the fifth general
flynn i mean all of these folks that
took place um that got together at the
january 5th hotel meeting i mean i think
each and every one of them knew well in
advance something that i've been talking
about for a long time now every single
one of them knew in advance what was
going to happen because donald told them
to do it i've stated this a million
times and it's worth repeating nothing
went on in the white house without
donald trump knowing about it firsthand
nothing ever went on at the trump
organization without donald trump
knowing about it firsthand from the
acquisition of real estate to the
purchasing of paper clips the man was
involved in every single aspect of both
the company and the white house which he
ran exactly the same way
did he pick the ketchup that he would
throw against the wall i'm just i'm
trying to figure out exactly how many
details because that was one of the
images that she gave us is that
she came in and this wasn't the first
time she had had witnessed this where he
had thrown his plate against the wall
because he was so mad and i guess the
ketchup you know thing kind of stands
out it's it's kind of a funny point but
i think the point she was trying to make
in her testimony is that he he really
was like this all the time when he
didn't get his way and it was obvious
the day of january 6 that he wasn't
getting his way mike pence wasn't doing
what he told him to do um people weren't
escorting him to the capitol like he
told them to do
they just weren't doing what he wanted
for the for them to make him king and
ultimately that's maybe why the ketchup
ended up on the wall i guess that's kind
of a funny side point but really into
all the seriousness here how dangerous
how dangerously close were we
to donald trump um
bullying these people into doing what he
wanted to do and tearing down our
democracy you have to give them you have
to give them a lot of credit for
standing up it is not easy and i've also
said this uh ad nauseam it is not easy
standing up to donald trump uh the guy
is beyond vindictive the man knows no
shame he has no empathy so he will go to
any length out there in order to get
what it is that he wants including
putting his own life and everybody
else's life in jeopardy by grabbing a
hold of a steering wheel while the beast
which is like a 20 000 pound vehicle i
mean the doors i don't know if you've
ever been in the beast or felt the beast
i've closed the doors um you know to the
beast um you know with myself when i was
allowed to sit inside of it um those
doors weigh like 10 000 pounds i mean
it's crazy and he grabbed the wheel of
the beast while it's in motion simply
because the
baby in chief wasn't getting what he
wanted he didn't get a chance to go
march with people he allowed weapons to
be you know brought close you know to uh
you know to the to the rally that he was
speaking he put everyone's life in
jeopardy but here's the thing that
cassidy stated and it's true his only
thought was that they will not hurt me
these are my people so he doesn't give a
[ __ ] if it was your life in jeopardy or
anybody else maybe a journalist from cnn
or msnbc or abc nbc cbs it didn't make a
difference to him who was there who can
get hurt knowing that they wouldn't hurt
him he wanted to be there he actually
wanted to walk them through the capital
that's how i see you know knowing him as
well as i do that's what he wanted to do
to lead the charge hoping that that
would intimidate mike pence to call the
whole thing off then he would end up
taking over and
remaining as president whether it was
for an extra day or an extra year or
whatever it might be the man is a
narcissistic sociopath who has
autocratic tendencies and
somehow or another he managed to
bamboozle his way you know into the
white house and become the worst version
of himself ever imaginable i never
thought that this would be the way that
i remember you know the legacy of donald
trump ever
well but speaking of legacy of donald
trump he's adding to the legacy this
afternoon by i know i guess you call it
truthing i i'm not really sure um i want
to bring those up real quick here um he
he
says he hardly knows who this person
cassie hussion is that's a very typical
um he didn't know who i was either
remember that right absolutely his
second one here from just uh you know 20
minutes after he says never complained
about crowd size it was massive um i
mean you know we can go back and read
these statements it's full of a bunch of
gibberish to be quite honest just
because he's he's [ __ ] lying here he
can't help himself but to lie it's
really ironic that this is truth i think
we have some more uh clips here uh here
here is another from 20 minutes later
her fake story that i tried to grab the
steering wheel of the white house
limousine in order to steer into the
capitol building is sick and fraudulent
very vigilant is the wrong word by the
way okay right well
you know when he's saying these things i
believe he's saying yes i did these i
have to say i didn't do these because i
did do these things
by making these statements he says very
much like the unselect committee itself
wouldn't even have been possible to do
such a ridiculous thing her story of me
throwing food
is also false and why would she i don't
know why you can't believe she there
have to clean it up i hardly knew who
she was okay first of all you may
remember in her testimony she didn't
have to clean it up she felt bad for the
man uh that was
um that was cleaning up and she lent a
hand that's generally what people do
right when you have empathy for another
person but then again he finishes it by
stating that he hardly knew who she was
that's the three d's of donald trump
right it's distance yourself denigrate
and then deflect to something else then
he goes on to talk about in the in the
last true social one that she changed
lawyers at the last time that happened
to me as well i was being bombarded by a
guy named costello who was involved with
giuliani who wanted to be part of the
defense team when
when i was um undergoing after the fbi
raid and uh the
alleged
uh you know
investigation into me and all that other
nonsense they wanted to put this guy
costello in they want their people in
the game in that way they could report
back so that you can be directed to stay
on message it's exactly how the mob
works the don tells you right no pun
intended here the don tells you use this
guy he's he's he's one of us he's part
of the family right he'll keep you safe
put your arms around them until you have
to shoot them that's what donald is all
about right denigrate
distance and then deflect onto something
else it's the three ds and he does the
same thing every time it's about time
that press and and you know um folks who
are supporters of trump start to see
this and rest assured i guarantee if i
go on to my cell phone right now i've
already received an email from donald
trump's uh what do you call it his
campaign finance you know organization
hey you know just got smashed and
attacked by the unselect committee send
15
right because we have to fight this i
guarantee you this
[ __ ] grifter in chief is going to do
everything in his power to suck even
more money out of this i mean it's funny
this is bothering him a lot it'll bother
him a lot worse if he doesn't make money
off of it but this is really bothering
him the fact that you have all of these
people coming together and corroborating
what we already know we've already read
the emails the text messages and so on
and the recordings we've already heard
seen and read these things so we knew
exactly what cassidy was going to be
responding to it was just nice to have
it coming first person from somebody
like myself who was a fly in the wall
during a certain period of time
michael i really appreciate you joining
us um i'm going to go to the panel here
but i i know your insight is always
valuable do you want to stick around for
the panel or do you have to or you have
to jump i'll stick around for you
okay yeah that sounds great that sounds
great you know you look you have a lot
of people that are on right now i i know
asking a million and one questions here
and um
there is a lot there is a lot of people
um let me bring in some of our panel
here um i thought we were going to have
some footage of interviews afterwards
but we're not going to have um that
going on i think i believe because
um they're cutting the footage i don't
think that they're letting the select
committee give interviews
uh after the fact here um and the and
the reason why is maybe because of
security i think they have some security
concerns
um i think i have everybody here yes i
do um jessica you had something that you
wanted to say personally about uh
trump and and maybe being pressured i
know
you have experience with this maybe you
give us insight into this
yeah i just wanted to to point out i
tweeted about this that that how i mean
if you're a woman who's lived this this
gas lighting this playbook and that
first tweet where he said
i've heard very negative things about
cassidy hutchinson she's bad news
um i know we all know this is complete
[ __ ] and gaslighting but to his
supporters this is the narrative that
goes out and i experienced this first
hand i mean i had an episode where i was
literally running an errand for stephen
miller one night going out picking
waiting for hours at a kinko's to pick
up the ken starr report that he so he
could have it the next day for a debate
and that night an insane insane rumor
when around trump tower that i have
learned about through the discovery in
my lawsuit where it was um being told
that i was rummaging through people's
offices through kellyanne conway's
office through dave fosse's office i was
called by my former boss this [ __ ] is
out of control what's her malfunction
um you know
basically bad news this woman is bad
news it is such a misogynist sick
card to play on women so
um you know i'm just i i dealt with this
in in silence and privacy in in enormous
she's she has kind of a separate
situation to deal with because she's
very public and i hope that publicity
gets her the protection that she needs
and i think it will i really pray and
hope that it does i was in a very
different scenario where i couldn't say
anything and i had to deal with all of
these lies and this this an unbelievable
pressure and slander in silence um and
so i you know i empathize with her on
that and and she is extraordinarily
brave again just i want to emphasize
what we started this conversation off
with that here is a woman who is it it's
a woman telling the truth it's a woman
dropping the bombs it's a woman
confronting the evil and it's going to
be women that bring this [ __ ]
down finally hold him accountable for
once and for all and demand that that we
move forward without this sickness and
poison in in the american fabric anymore
uh karen i want to go to you too but i
want to pull up while you're while
you're talking here because i want to go
to the former prosecutor um because i i
think i think it it just seems to be
that um
maybe the
assumption that jessica was making at
the break that maybe something is coming
from doj that that
not
just that speculation that possibly this
is the reason why they wanted to get
this out in the open as fast as they
possibly could um do you think you think
we'll see people like mark meadows and
handcuffs by the end of the week i you
know i just i think the world wants to
know
i you gotta unmute there
sorry thank you
um it seems to me the the two things
that that struck me about uh about this
testimony today
was i i believe that the select
committee is working close with the
department of justice
because i they don't want to do anything
to disrupt the investigation in any way
or create any kind of issue or situation
where
witnesses are testifying that they they
might not want to testify publicly um so
i think that this must be coordinated
and i do believe something is coming out
with mark meadows you know a lot of um
a lot of what ms hutchinson talked about
was uh was all of what mr meadows was
doing and more importantly not doing and
you know when she talked about the three
camps you know the ivanka was in the
camp of you know stop them make them
stop there was the neutral camp and then
there was the meadows
and and trump camp and i i think it's
pretty clear
that she is um
is going to be a critical witness
against mark meadows and that the
department of justice it seems to me
that that's sort of the next step in
this investigation and prosecution
they're getting closer and i think that
potentially is why she testified now so
that the american people would
understand and know exactly what his
culpability was
what um a little bit of giuliani and his
and donald trump um and i think i do
think it's a coordinated effort to
um to let people know kind of what the
evidence is what the testimony is the
other thing i thought was sort of
interesting
in addition to the things that everyone
else already talked about and uh you
know just about the violence and the
being out of control and being emotional
and i agree with michael that it sounds
very much like a
you know a mafia playbook you know the
way he he runs things but the thing that
i thought was was quite um interesting
was the two were the two closing
statements by um
representative uh thompson and cheney
where they both basically um
was talking about kind of witness
tampering and witness threats
and so i i really felt like they were
sending a message that you know we know
your playbook we know that you call
people up and
and say things like you know
like you know we know you're a team
player or you'll be taken care of and
that that those are being viewed as
threats and
uh and that they're not going to take
that lightly and if you do threaten
witnesses before they come here we will
um take that very seriously i don't
think it's a coincidence that they did
that with her testimony
today i think they were clearly sending
a message that that's what they're doing
and that they're on to them and that
they better [ __ ] stop because it's
outrageous and so i do think it's those
two things
um
that this hearing kind of you know why
it was today and why it was an emergency
i agree with all of the things you guys
you you were saying earlier tony that um
you think it's about threats i think
that was very clear with those closing
statements that that's what it's about
but i do think the the the circle is
closing in on the inner circle getting
closer to the white house and i think
today was was mostly about meadows and
reconstructing uh
the day the january 6 kind of um what
trump was doing and where he was i i
wouldn't be surprised if
if they're getting closer to finally
prosecuting him
well
you know
tony can go ahead and jump in here one
quick second because karen's spot on on
that with the witness statement and um
you know one of the things that i've
also you know frequently stated is the
way that they operate is they put the
lawyer in with you but i just want to go
through the witness statement if i may
uh you know that was put out by uh
congresswoman cheney when they
what they said to me is as long as i
continue to be a team player they know
that i'm on the team i'm doing the right
thing i'm protecting who i need to
protect you know i'll continue to stay
in good graces in trump world and they
have reminded me a couple of times that
trump does read transcripts and just to
keep that in mind as i proceed through
my depositions and interviews with the
committee it's almost exactly the same
as the text messages emails things that
were sent to me by guys like costello
and and giuliani and a couple of
messages that would come in from other
people that were still in trump world as
i was testifying um before the various
different committees at the beginning of
the investigations um you know like like
i said boy you know congresswoman cheney
is really um she's she's really just a
beast i mean the way she's handling
these proceedings i mean she
in and of herself really deserves some
type of a congressional award uh for
doing what she's doing and remember she
too put her own career on the line here
so you know that has to be noted
especially the fact that she's a
republican
david did you have something that you
wanted to add i i did and and and
michael uh and and jessica both of you
have been on the inside of this uh and
and indeed michael you just made the
point that i i was
i i was remembering what happened uh
when uh you uh went through
uh
this initial period and were receiving
those messages i think i think some of
them were even taped uh
messages to you
uh let me ask you something
if if you experienced this both of you
saw how this playbook went out what's
going on right now
uh now that this has happened
we see it on truth social we know he's
not writing a lot of it because it's
spelled properly
so
what is going on what is their playbook
now that
uh these people are cooperating what in
your view for from the inside both of
you having seen it what's he gonna do
now this must be killing him
yeah there's no doubt that he's really
angry right now but here's the donald
trump playbook
something roy cohn the famous attorney
once taught him when he was a kid
deny deny deny all right you know no
fingerprints for me considering i have
no email you're not seeing any
handwritten notes like you're seeing
from meadows it wasn't me it's somebody
else and that's why i think that the
next group of people that you're going
to start seeing fbi agents showing up on
giuliani meadows
chipoloni you're going to start seeing a
whole slew of these folks now um
getting patted down by fbi agents it's
really bad for all of them because
remember donald trump has no loyalty we
always used to say in the office he's
like first avenue right one way and he
doesn't give a rat's ass about any of
these folks and as long as he can escape
responsibility something he has done his
entire life he will use whatever levers
of power that he still has and he will
make sure that each and every one of
these folks ends up under the bus well
in advance of him are you betting that
he will escape guarantee i don't believe
that he is going to be um indicted for
any of this i i don't but i believe that
everyone else around him will i do
believe charges may be brought but i
think it's gonna be very difficult when
the man once again you're not gonna find
anything from donald that turns around
and says handwritten documents emails
text messages he doesn't do these things
he was taught as a kid no fingerprints
on anything and he's managed to escape
liability his whole entire life
using that you know using that um game
plan
i want to say um right there yeah
yeah i'm going to take michael to task
on that
let's let's just um let's change the
expectations michael that we've had for
his whole life let's let's bring justice
to bear on this situation donald trump
is going to be indicted because donald
trump needs to be indicted his
fingerprints are all over the television
screens and twitter and everything else
they have been for a year and a half for
god's sakes with the american people
know and the justice department knows i
know
i know you and i michael have been
through hell you've been through much
more than i have you're you've been in
prison but but but don't let that don't
let that taint your faith in the justice
system working now this this hearing it
is late
too much time has passed too much damage
has been done but now is the moment when
these these unfathomable bombshells one
after another i heard someone tweet that
this is like after the second bombshell
it just put you know john dean is like
you know way way in the
doesn't even compare to the bombshells
of today's testimony we we cannot move
past this as as a society without donald
trump being charged and we will demand
it and it will happen so let's raise the
expectations and and expect
finally the right thing to happen um the
question that david asked when he
started off this question to me and
michael was what happens next yes donald
trump will continue to gaslight his cult
they will continue to be
mobilized to the point of terrorism by
him you know what stops that for once
and for all a criminal indictment
putting donald trump behind bars a man
in prison does not have the same effect
on a cult following than a free man
living on a golf course so that's what
happens next tweet a little more on your
untruth unsocial and then face face the
fire that you've been avoiding your
whole life because it's coming trump so
jessica let me then respond back to you
for a quick second because i like you
have wanted to see donald indicted
incarcerated for his crimes now i've
been very clear and i've said it on
television also many many times i don't
want to see donald trump or anybody
indicted incarcerated um because i
despise them i dislike them i disagree
fundamentally with everything that they
stand for i want to see them indicted
and incarcerated for for crimes that can
be proven now remember one of the big
problems that we have here is you are
still talking about a former president
of the united states and the system as i
have unfortunately learned is not
designed in order to deal with somebody
like donald trump rest assured i like
you and virtually everybody that's
probably watching this i want to see him
indicted all right i want to see i
wanted to see alvin bragg do what he was
supposed to do after i gave 14 different
um you know uh meetings with them over
you know a two and a half year period um
i wanted to see indictments coming out
of the d.a no different then i was happy
to see stuff coming out of georgia and i
was happy to see these hearings moving
forward nevertheless this is still
america i don't have a lot of faith in
the department of justice simply because
i went through it and i understand so
much better now than i've ever
understood it before that the department
of is designed to protect the entire
institution not an individual because
there's so much corruption that's going
on there and specifically with this gop
they all need to be indicted only
difference they don't have the um the
power that the president had remember
you know this guy also was given four
years of national security information
right at these briefings very difficult
to put somebody with that information in
prison because donald trump would sell
that information for a bag of freaking m
m's and michael in fairness you dealt
with a different doj
this is a doj now not under bill barr
but under merrick garland and we're
seeing these things happening in real
time we're seeing what happened to
eastman we're seeing what's happening
now
uh with the doj that is determined
apparently to pursue the facts where
they lead which is what he pledged to do
and this public hearing is pushing them
in that direction so i agree with you
when you were dealing with the doj it
was a very different you know circle the
wagons no collusion no obstruction we
heard that from bill barr for a month
before the report was released so
i i think jessica has a point i think we
may have finally reached a place
where with this happening in public
this is he was taught from birth not to
do emails not to leave notes to burn
everything but he's doing it in plain
sight
so
david do you remember you ever hear the
old you ever hear the expression david
from your mouth to god's ears
yes all right
from your mouth to god's ears i'm just
let me just say i'm less uh i'm i'm more
skeptical than than you are about trump
i believe he will be indicted there's no
doubt in my mind for for one of the many
alleged illegalities that he has been
involved with i just believe that you
know um actually finding him guilty will
be much more difficult than people
believe so so let me let me uh because i
actually agree with all of you that um
because i think it's it's very difficult
um
right exactly
how much respect i have for michael and
his experience and what he's done and i
do not question his his personal lived
experience and i want i just wanted to
bring full circle on one thing that
michael said he said i don't want to do
this for because i'm you know out of
vindication or you know retribution and
i think that's really important i mean
we've got a panel here of you know three
six seven people who really really want
to see donald trump indicted but that's
not what this is about this justice is
not a zero-sum game this is even if
donald trump is indicted and you know
god willing actually put in a
penitentiary it will be the biggest gift
that this man has ever given because he
will have to face the truth something
that he's never lived he has lived a lie
his whole life so it's actually a
blessing to everyone including donald
trump all right well so so i want to say
that i think it is difficult um the the
indictment seems to be easy the trial
the process will be a long process um
through the court and through a trial
system
and maybe even a jury selection could be
very difficult and i'm going to go to
karen here because she she she has a
little more expertise than most of us on
this panel
about this
but i i am very very very
concerned and i want to
give people the idea that
we have never put a former president of
the united states in a penitentiary we
have never incarcerated one so we don't
know what that is we don't know what
that means we don't know what a federal
judge would do because karen
am i correct in saying that a federal
judge would actually dictate it within
if he is indicted if he's convicted if a
jury finds him guilty of of charges
a judge gets to decide his fate in that
moment um tell us a little bit about
that because i think
rather he's indicted and he's convicted
and the jury finds him guilty i think
the american people
that will give them some kind of you
know
glad feeling but having a former
president locked up we don't know what
that looks like and a federal judge has
a lot to do with that decision how do
you see
if donald trump were to
face indictment and be
found guilty
would he serve time you think
so don't forget he could be prosecuted
either in state court or federal court
as michael pointed out alvin bragg the
manhattan d.a had a pending case or had
a case an investigation against him uh
that um they did not bring and um still
people are still hoping that he will but
there's also investigation in georgia
you know when he said you know find the
votes find the 12 000 votes so it could
be state court it could be federal court
as you said it's very clear that the
department of justice is investigating
him
and
uh then if he were to be prosecuted he
would be arrested he'd be brought before
a judge and a judge would decide whether
or not he during the pendency of his
case whether he would be incarcerated
pre-trial
whether he's a flight risk or a risk um
you know a danger to society and and
those are the the um balancing sort of
that you know that that they would they
would um do whether he could have house
arrest or an ankle monitor i mean
there's very different
ways that a federal judge could decide
what to do pre-trial
with him
he would then be prosecuted like anybody
else and he would have to be indicted he
would be prosecuted he would then go to
trial and
he'd probably have a jury trial i i i'm
almost 100 sure it would be a jury trial
um and then
you know it would they would present
evidence it would have to be
admissible evidence and interestingly
these hearings which have been
phenomenal uh
some of some of what they present is
hearsay and so some of what they have
presented would require a live testimony
and not just the hearsay that they have
so
i'm sure the federal prosecutors are
watching these hearings to see
what evidence would be admissible
evidence um and then you know it goes to
a jury and a jury decides and um
of course the sentence is is up to the
judge um if he is convicted and uh yes
he could go to prison for sure for all
of these crimes some that that's just
sort of the process you're right that
that there's no sitting united states
president who's ever been prosecuted um
we have i'm sure
prosecuted other uh you know we like to
to
be the world's um
police and so
i'm sure there have been former other
kind of presidents in other countries
that we have prosecuted for various
corruption um
you know and um
yeah but we've never
but we've never prosecuted a president a
former president of the united states um
in the criminal justice system as as we
know nixon was pardoned um kind of right
away so he never faced you know he was
the closest we got he was he he never
faced um
prosecution so you know we'll see
we will see i think it's happening i
think he's going to be uh i think the
cuffs are going to go on him i don't
know if it's state or federal but i
think someone's going to do it and then
i think others are going to do it i
think it's just going to take someone to
go first and as soon as somebody goes
first i think
yeah i actually don't get together
who we love that here to michael's point
uh about him selling information
there's a way to lock somebody up where
they have no contact and i think that
was true with noriega no contact
whatsoever with the outside world
i'll tell you that
rather he gets locked up or not he is
absolutely terrified this afternoon um
before before i go to some of these uh
truths or whatever the hell they're
called that he's putting out here on on
his uh his fraudulent social media site
tooth central as he calls it at his
rallies i want to um give everybody the
chance to go over to
store.minustouch.com get your convict or
convict 45 the union made
in the usa enamel pen just used it i
like convict by the way
i i do i like
you know
i just wanted to bring up one one thing
i know this is going to seem almost
comical though it's obviously not but as
the former president he is entitled to
secret service protection for the rest
of his life could you imagine if in fact
he does get locked up i wonder if the
secret service agents have to go with
them
wouldn't that be something what what a
way to pull a detail on that
well and that's why i i say i don't know
what it looks like i don't know what a
fed it doesn't look like it doesn't look
like what happened with noriega in miami
by the way in all fairness noriega had a
cadre of people he had his own specific
block and he had people working for him
while he was there it's a it's a very
famous story uh but
yes i totally agree um
it's never happened i agree with karen
100 it's never happened in the united
states and i think
merrick garland fears that it would be
setting a precedent for other presidents
then or other um parties to go after
members of the competing party in the
future right
something that merrick garland is really
truly concerned about
uh texas paul i know you've been waiting
patiently because i know he's got a ton
of notes here i know he does but i i
want to bring you up but i want to go to
because i know these things really piss
you off um but here is here's some more
of these these truce i guess that he's
putting out uh he misspelled cheney here
uh chaney conveniently left out the
snippet in my speech to quote go
peacefully and patriotically of course
the capitalization doesn't make much
sense here um and isn't she disgraceful
and he seems really terrified of darth
vader junior excuse me liz cheney as i
refer to a dirt bear junior but he also
tweet our truce out here whatever again
whatever the hell it's called um he puts
out in the statement here he says there
is no cross-examination of this
so-called witness this is a kangaroo
court i
you know i always have said that it was
a cheeto dust kangaroo coup so maybe it
is appropriate that donald trump uh in
on his fraudulent social refers to this
as a kangaroo court and but we must not
forget that the person who questioned
the witness almost the entire time is a
republican not a democrat a republican
and most democrats wouldn't vote for her
if they're if if she was the last
politician on earth this is not some
kind of liberal
democrat uh uh
radical it's liz cheney that was
questioning her the entire time so what
do you make of his statements versus the
testimony today obviously he's a whiny
little [ __ ] but what do you make of it
texas paul give us give the midas mighty
the the texas paul version here
he's [ __ ] terrified
he's [ __ ] terrified this is not a
court
this is a political exercise and he
knows he lost
that's exactly what this is is crowd
control
they have laid it out from the beginning
donald trump in the fir before the
election tried to use the joy and local
states like ken paxton here
said said it out loud if it wasn't for
me donald trump would have lost texas
that was before the election they laid
out that he was told by everyone around
him that he lost
he went into steel mode he tried to use
the same legislatures that he tried to
steal the election with to
try to steal it again i mean he after
the fact
then he tried to use the doj then he
tried to use the military when all of it
failed he tried to use the proud wars
and the oath keepers to to to try to
hold on to power
it all failed he is [ __ ]
terrified and he is going to burn
there is no way he walks away from this
i don't care what anybody says that's
exactly what this is
is this is a political exercise to
prepare the nation for the fact
that
we are going to start seeing
people all around donald trump and karen
knows how it works you don't start
convicting at the top you flip them one
after the other after the other after
the other after the other today's
testimony was to give you the clearest
shittiest picture possible of donald
trump
so that people don't riot
so that people don't
you know there's no valid claim that
he's innocent
this this is all a political exercise to
free merrick garland up to do exactly
what he has already planned to do they
are coordinating they are coordinating
this is the public
face of it
but donald trump is [ __ ] for all
eternity there's no way he walks away
from this there's too much out there too
many people you know you're right his
fingerprints aren't on it but when you
have 15 people around you saying
he did it
he told me to [ __ ] do it
i guarantee you there's not a jury in
this country that is going to let donald
trump walk away unless they end up with
some maga [ __ ] on there some
cult member
this is over that's exactly what this is
and and i will give you this hat tony if
i am wrong
i may be holding him to that hat because
i happen to like it all right walking
around the streets of manhattan you know
especially now that we have the open gun
law um
look i'm with you on everything that you
say except for one thing i was there
with the creation of this playbook and
i'm telling you the fact that his
fingerprints are not on anything and you
could have a hundred people it's still
it's still here say show me the
documentary evidence to which that we
could corroborate other than other
people it's a very tough case for a
prosecutor and look i want him to be
held accountable for something i mean
for god's sakes i went to prison
because i paid a porn star who pulled
the president's mushroom pecker end of
story that's the only legitimate charge
despite i had to plead guilty to others
i don't know if i if you read this or
i've told it to you they threatened to
indict my wife and i had 48 hours from
start to finish of my case so and i have
a book that's going to come out about
this relatively soon called the
department of injustice that's why i'm
so um down on them they need a massive
overhaul and i hate to say it i don't
believe merrick garland has the cojones
to do it actually i'm pretty certain
because this is a big moment in american
history it's a huge moment all right i
do believe he gets this brilliant woman
right here ask this brilliant woman
right here to my right
point this point this way yeah this way
texas park
no you know what i actually the vote
i heard him say it i saw him say it and
i guarantee you mark meadows is a [ __ ]
and i know i'm going to catch so much
hell for using that euphemism from the i
know don't stop typing i know
but he is a [ __ ] he is and he will just
argue here say it's an odd statement
he
told me not i heard him say
not some blow you know it you know
i guarantee you that is not hearsay
i think i think
i think though
put it putting that aside um i've always
said i think that the the best case is
the georgia case and that phone call is
on tape and that's trump's words himself
and when you put that all together in
context with all this other evidence of
what his intent was and what he was
looking for and that he knew that the
election was not stolen from him it
wasn't a big you know fraud
et cetera et cetera and that's on tape
that's his own words that's why i think
that's the case that needs to be brought
because you you know you you can prove
that he knew that he was told over and
over and over and over again that that
and both by judges in court and by his
lawyers and
by everybody else and then he still
calls up and makes that recording on
tape i think that's absolutely the um
the case that needs to be brought and
why i've always said that's the case um
that needs to happen plus i i agree
there is a question with merrick garland
about setting precedent and about you
know
worrying about the legitimacy of you
know any any sort of prosecution by
someone who is appointed by a democrat
you know and and and worrying about the
future you know i do think there's a
little reticence there um but i i that's
why i think georgia needs to do it and
um hopefully alvin bragg will still do
it but i do think i do think merrick
garland's gonna do it um and i do and i
think that if enough people i think
michael has a point he doesn't have
fingerprints anywhere but i think if
enough people come forward and have
there's power in numbers i think that's
going to be enough um even if there are
no recordings and no papers and
pardons so let me say you prosecutors
are lone rangers none of you are you
know damn well y'all work together y'all
y'all know damn well you work together
they're gonna bury him under so many
freaking prosecutions he's going to have
he is going to have
so many people coming into him from
science i agree if someone has to go
first someone has to go first if
somebody goes first i think the others
are going to fall
yeah the one that should have gone first
would have been alvin bragg despite the
fact that he allowed
your limitations to run on that case and
i'll tell you why i want everybody to
remember
who's the most famous gangster out there
that they couldn't prosecute for the
murders and all the other stuff but they
got him on the table
on taxes all right they had them on the
taxes they have him who's that last week
i know or was that you texas
all right i know for a fact the
documents because i spent so much time
with them why they allowed this to walk
away
who cares what's the reason that the man
is behind bars who cares which is the
illegal actions taken by donald that
puts him away and out of our lives no
one so they should have gone with the
low-hanging fruit instead
finding you know
one out of 12 jurors who's going to be a
trump sycophant acolyte follower is
going to be real difficult right and
that one person can hold up the entire
the entire thing cause mistrials and so
on this is not an easy case and um they
should have gone after the low-hanging
fruit put the guy's ass away you know
makes no difference to me if it's the
sedition argument whether it's trying to
attempt a coup or tax evasion makes no
difference at all
yeah and i mean
really quick read mark pomerantz's
resignation letter in the you know he
was the prosecutor under alvin bragg
read his resignation letter he says
there is no perfect case but this case
we have enough let's bring it you know
and that is true there is no perfect
case and but but prosecutors do it all
the time every single day and i
completely agree michael that case
should have been brought and
um and alvin who you know i obviously
love the manhattan da's office and think
very highly of it um i think this was
just the wrong
yeah
call
terrible call but just going back to
merrick garland and what um
the presumed pressure that he's under to
set a precedent of charging a a former
president and the notion that that might
be a bad precedent i think is just
ludicrous first of all donald trump set
his own ludicrous precedent of being
president in the first place so we have
to counter that with the appropriate
action um last week we had that
kind of
what i considered to be an article that
really sold a lot of doubt and concerns
by jonah goldberg i think michael
referenced it last week um about the
possible ramifications political you
know framing of a prosecution of donald
trump and then on friday there was an
excellent follow-up piece by rick hassan
and the new york times that kind of got
you know overrun by the roe news about
why any possible risks of indicting
donald trump are far outweighed by the
need to the absolute need to and we do
have these other cases i have a lot of
faith like karen does in georgia and
fanny willis um but i think that from a
federal standpoint i mean we're talking
about a treater a traitor here a man who
committed treason there should be a
federal record for history um in our
country even if prosecution is hard even
if it doesn't result in conviction that
those federal charges from the
department of justice are brought and
going back to the role that we play
because i i don't have enormous faith in
merrick garland either i wish that
someone of a you know more
maybe a stronger individual was chosen
for that role i think you and i the
american people just like we flooded the
streets um you know to protest for
george floyd and all these social
justice justice movements le the way we
flooded the streets to you know protest
against roe versus wade
we we need to show that we are demanding
this i was outside scotus after the
leaked opinion i said to one of the
organizers i said do you think we could
get this same energy at the department
of justice and she's like yeah i think
so because it's damn well as important
if i mean it's as important there is
nothing more important to our future as
a free people and holding donald trump
accountable so
us out here in society we have a role by
by making our voices heard if it
requires you know michael and i have
talked about this there are risks
involved getting people to you know
stand and demand protest demand that the
department of justice take action um and
let them know that we will stand for
nothing less so i i i want to go to some
more
jesus some more truths gabe has put him
up here for me but before that a
social media we're going to talk about
social media here everyone follow the
midas touch youtube channel here um go
ahead and hit the subscribe button like
and share this this hearing with your
family and friends we're going to be
back in july or any other special type
of hearings that they have that they
urgently call
we'll be back with those hearings right
here on the midas media network so be
sure to follow the midas touch youtube
channel and go over and follow the tony
michael's podcast on youtube as well you
can catch on minus touch you can catch
legal af you can catch michael's show
here on the midas touch youtube channel
as well so follow us and also all the
great uh react videos from texas paul
so don't miss those on the midas touch
youtube channel and do me a favor go
over to the tony michaels podcast and
follow our channel as well i want to
bring up this other here's another he
he's on a tirade here i mean he just
can't stop it's her body language is
that of a total bull artist fantasy land
i have no idea what eve what the hell
that even means um and then he says well
everybody will anybody ever be allowed
to say that the election was rigged or
stole it you keep yammering on about it
you chucklehead will the unselects ever
discuss that our country is going to
hell because of a fraudulent election
how about analyzing election results
this is all again just complete utter
nonsense um from the former gang himself
gabe what do you make of the you're
you're you're looking at true social
right now
i'm listening to the panel in the in the
background i'm following along i he just
keeps posting and i cannot keep up to
make these graphics but he is he said
everything from what you just said as
well as he has some additional ones
where he said a total phony he said i
never said mike pence deserves it to be
hung another made up statement by third
rate social climber bad handwriting that
of a wacko question mark why didn't they
use the 10 000 troops that i offered on
january 3rd
there would have been no january 6th so
he's you know
he he's he's really he's doing those 3
a.m rage post where he sits on the
[ __ ] and he's just going at it and
right now i just can't keep up with them
but i mean like looking at this i just
have to agree
uh with everything that people are
saying is like he well i think also in
addition to that he is going to um
he might even say something that he
doesn't mean to say he might admit to
something that you know in his rage he
goes ahead and says just
you know and hands up to someone that
might be investigating him i don't know
but
uh you know it's it really does tell you
we heard it during the testimony he
tried to grab the wheel he tried to
choke the secret agent he was throwing
food against the wall donald trump is a
child he is having a tantrum and right
now he is kicking and screaming in
mar-a-lago upset because these truths
have come out and now he's trying to use
truth social to truth himself out of the
actual truth
so
it's completely ridiculous i mean we do
again we have a child that was a that
was a president he is completely having
a tantrum and the guy is
he's right you can't you can't write
this
she's terrified liz cheney beat the [ __ ]
out of him politically
she beat the living [ __ ] out of him
politically and he knows it well i'll
tell you i'll tell you uh texas paul
probably knows this uh growing up in in
texas when you when you corner when you
corner a a rabid you know possum
in a corner they are they are very angry
and they start screaming and screeching
and whacking their tail and actually
kissing at you that's exactly what's
happening he is trapped he's in a corner
he knows he knows that he he has nowhere
to go here um so he's lashing out and i
know michael probably knows this better
than anybody else
tony let me chime in on this one all
right because there's two donald trumps
here something that everybody has to
understand there's the donald trump who
has moments of clarity where he realizes
that liz cheney who is the daughter of
the former vice president from 2001 to
2009 under george bush all right another
republican is the one that's leading the
charge against him so how is it a
kangaroo court considering the committee
is not even a court as texas paul put it
before but then there's the other donald
trump and this donald trump i hate to
say
takes up most of the brain
whatever's there uh in donald trump
whereby he's so myopic if
on truth social people start responding
back to him saying yeah donald you won
yeah donald you're the greatest you're
my fuhrer right um you know they stole
the election from you all of this said
by um you know by uh you know by the
select the select committee and by all
the witnesses is all a lie what he does
then is he focuses laser focuses on that
specific response back and then that
becomes the 100 denominator it's a very
sick and demented um
issue that goes on in between donald's
ears
so we got just a few minutes left i want
to give everyone one last chance to make
a statement about the testimony today
but also
going forward what they maybe expect
from the committees as you heard liz
cheney and benny thompson at the end of
the hearing kind of give a projection of
what is going to happen in the hearings
that we may uh that we're going to have
in july maybe even sooner we don't know
so i want to go around the the table
here i'll start with karen karen what is
your what is your
opinion your last thought of the hearing
today and going forward what these
hearings will bring
so you know it's just interesting that
donald trump's tweet was how come
nobody's testifying about the fraud
um you know about the stolen election
but you know it's very clear that um
everyone who could
give that you know ridiculous uh opinion
has taken the fifth so
you know they they won't they they can't
say it because they know that's
incriminating because there is no fraud
it wasn't stolen and um and it's not the
big lie it's the big crime so that's
what these hearings in my opinion have
shown is that this is the big crime and
i look forward to seeing
the house of cards uh that is going to
come down around him uh in the coming
weeks and months with hopefully
prosecution after prosecution after
prosecution and we're all going to look
back at this horrible dark time in our
life and
and and move on the other thing i just
want to say is it's ridic it's so clear
that that cassidy hutchinson got under
his skin he can't stop tweeting like
it's like i didn't realize you know it's
just so easy to get under this man's
skin anyway those are my final thoughts
and thank you all thank you for caring
um spending the day together
yes good jessica to you
um
yeah let me just bring it back to where
we started today you know we've got a
threat of fascism on two fronts we've
got uh you know fascists trying to run
the right wing and really minority rule
this country and then we've got um
impunity for fascists which is what we
witnessed again today and we're about to
go into
you know
a week or so here independence day
the foundation of our country you know
separation from a king separation from
um
church having rule over over people and
the separation of church and state
that's fundamental to our our
founding doc it's our constitution our
freedom
um i just want to remind everyone what
what a pivotal moment in history we are
living through
you and i you've joined us on this
network this network i know i'm so
grateful to be included in is all about
our role what we can do to make sure
that democracy democracy survives and
does not become something that um you
know was a nice idea in history for a
few hundred years so um i just want to
leave everybody with that gravity like i
said in the in the open i'm so grateful
that we had this unexpected hearing
today and oh my god what a hearing it
was it was it was paul to you um give us
your last thoughts there and then i'll
go to michael
thank you michael cohen uh for
everything you've been through and
everything that you've brought out into
the public light
um you were the start of the downhill
slide for donald trump everything else
everything prior to them
and all the crime and stuff that had
been going on everything had been going
uphill for him but it'll be a long haul
but you will see some event you will see
him in an orange jumpsuit and i am truly
grateful to you my predictions are that
mike flynn's in ends up committing
suicide
mark meadows is going to prison he is a
[ __ ]
um and he today he
everything that he kept his mouth shut
for
went out the window today
i mean he's got nothing to offer cassidy
hutchinson put him in jail
there's no deal that he can make after
this other than pointing the finger and
say he may be able to shave some time
god that's caring about that but
um
rudy giuliani is done
he's done he is going to prison
uh we haven't even gotten to the
violence part yet
we know that there are more hearings
coming where they're going to be uh
talking about who coordinated with the
oath keepers who coordinated with
um
the
proud boys and the fir
1a predatorians that are so tight with
mike flynn
um yeah liz cheney isn't done with
donald trump by a damn site
um and
[Music]
he's going to burn
he is so going to burn
well i appreciate
the the words there paul everyone hears
that minus mighty loves the the way paul
puts things so thanks for joining us
paul michael what's your final thoughts
here on the hearings but but the
hearings going forward as well yeah so
first let me thank texas paul for you
know the kind words so i'll share just a
personal um you know
it's very difficult to put into words
the way the system when it breaks you it
breaks you um you know i do what i do
simply you know um as redemption i know
that you know i'm in part responsible
for the creation of frankenstein's
monster and my hope is that um
we're able to re-cage the beast before
he destroys our democracy i have
children and so on i have you know
nieces nephews i have you know a pretty
large family and they deserve the
democracy that we have
come to know and um
we need to change so much in this
country including the supreme court with
the way that they're running amok right
now but to touch on the hearing so i do
thank you for that uh you know i work on
myself every day i'm you know i i put on
the fun facade but inside you know
people who have done time will tell you
uh you're broken inside and it takes a
long time if ever you know to become
yourself again
um as it relates to the hearings you
know yeah i appreciate all the stuff
that's come out from cassidy um you know
from angle from donahoe from rosen from
all of the witnesses i only wish like
what i did that they would have come out
earlier and maybe none of this would
even be relevant right now
maybe there would have been a way to
overturn trump's decisions to put these
three animals on the supreme court
there's so many things that i wish that
they would have come out earlier with uh
whether it's the first impeachment or
the second that would have been the
right thing to do not post fact i hate
when that when that happens and i'm
gonna tell you my reason why
the bigger fear that we have to have is
not donald trump
re-running for president i've told
everybody a long time now he's not
running the guy has more problems than
anybody can even imagine he deserves and
hopefully he will be indicted his
company is going to go under you know
he's not going to be running again and
he also cannot handle being a two-time
loser that's one of the things that is
really keeping him away from the
campaign trail but what we all have to
be concerned about and you know midas
touch is so on top of this all of us
that are on this panel you know
constantly talk about it what happens
with the next one the donald trump 2.0
like iran desantis who's smarter than
trump that's for sure who's probably
better financed with you know um with
the republican party than trump you know
than trump would be um and somebody
who's potentially more devious and
more
disrespectful to the constitution hard
to imagine than donald that's the guy
that we have to be worried about because
donald has now given him a playbook on
how to overthrow the government how to
destroy our democracy and how to
basically you know um tear up our
constitution so we all need to stay
vigilant and keep doing what we're doing
thanks to everybody that joined us today
you know obviously take care of midas if
you can stay stay with all of us um you
know keep tuning in because there's so
much more to come
i appreciate all of you being here and
and thank you for for joining us and i
want to thank the audience again um i
hope that all of you come back i want to
give a few more shout outs uh here as
far as plugs again follow the midas
touch youtube channel because you will
not only find these hearings there you
will find the midas touch podcast you
will find legal af which karen is a
co-host on wednesdays you will find maya
culpa with michael cohen you'll find his
podcast here as well you'll find all the
videos from texas paul and also go
follow jessica denson on twitter she is
the trump nda killer i know she's going
to have a lot of stuff that she's going
to be putting out uh over the next
several months about some of the cases
that she is in at jessica denson that's
d-e-n-s-o-n-07 jessica denson07 i really
appreciate all of you joining us today
and being with us and staying with us
through the hearing i know this has been
one of the most groundbreaking ones
we've had so far because it has some of
the material in it that we've all been
waiting for we all we all felt like we
knew this or we heard this or they've
been reported on this but now we have
finally come to the moment where we see
this evidence being spoken and being
testified to i want to tell you that i
think these hearings coming up
are uh because liz cheney and vinnie
thompson pointed to this at the very end
and
he was they were very
and they kept giving these little
nuggets did you get any notice that they
give these little nuggets throughout the
hearing and the upcoming hearings and
the upcoming hearings and the upcoming
hearings it's almost like they have a
producer doing this to to tie you into
these these new episodes and to keep you
viewing and to keep you seeing this
evidence so i implore you i implore you
follow midas touch youtube channel and
go over do me a favor and give a favor
and go over and follow our our youtube
channel the tony michaels podcast but
follow both of those
those youtube channels because we are
going to follow these hearings wherever
they may go and we are also going to
have our great panel of guests um i want
to thank david bender is not here and
rachel biddikoffer is not here and i
also want to thank the mizellas brothers
now ben joined us earlier i know brett
and jordy apparently jordy is working on
stealing texas falls cookies and and
brett was out today but i appreciate
them as well with all the help and i
want everyone to thank gabe sanchez for
all the great graphics i know he's got
it he's he's got all these true socials
that he
that he was able to to wrestle up uh
till the very end even though
and we there's probably a thousand more
where that yeah there's definitely more
coming but yeah so thank you very much
to the midas mighty for joining us for
this hearing don't forget to join us for
all the other hearings but also don't
forget to subscribe and click the bell
notification for all the notifications
for all the great videos that will come
out uh thank you panel for joining us
gabe
stick around here i want to i want to
ask you about this true social real
quick thank you thank you all to our
guest thank you very much see you guys
later
uh gabe so let's let's go back real
quick to the yeah that's not even all of
them either i've got a total of 12 but i
i stopped i just stopped making the
graphics after a moment it was just uh
i
they are insane because they're either
just like statements like bad
handwriting that of a wacko like what is
he a total phony
i mean i'm personally a big fan of the i
never said mike pence deserves to be
hung in parentheses another made-up
statement by a third-rate social climber
like i think you know there's a lot of
projection happening here where he knows
he did something wrong clearly because
he did it but and also in his mind he
might not even think that he was in the
wrong like he wasn't in the wrong to try
to choke out a surface a secret service
agent right like he wasn't in the wrong
to fling food across the
the room like
in what world do we live in where the
sitting president is trying to
physically assault the people that are
trying to protect him and he's trying to
make a mess of things in the oval office
again he's just a top like he he's a kid
having a tantrum
wanting to go to [ __ ] bizarro world
disney world
right and the parents like no you know
what we're turning the car around and
we're going home and that is the oval
office and he just doesn't want to
doesn't want to have it doesn't doesn't
want to be
he's convict45 he's convict 45 or
convict 45 oh yeah i mean you can
convict 45 to become convict 45 there is
a transfer
of the title meaning well well i i want
to give one last shout out for for jordy
he was um wanting this this promo code
justice if you go to
store.minustouch.com
use the promo code justice get 10 off i
think there's only just a handful of
these enamel pens left or union made in
the usa whether it's convict 45 or
convict 45 go get it now
supplies are very very limited if
they're not out already so run over to
store.mondust.com use the promo code
justice get 10 off not just the pen but
the the entire store over there at
store.minustouch.com
uh gabe i i'm really looking forward to
this uh these other hearings as vinnie
thompson and
and
liz cheney give these sprinkles of
evidence throughout and what a what a
what a fantastic
i mean like you said they're doing a
good job you know the through uh
producer kind of guidance to say you
know next week on
the [ __ ] show that is the january 6th
you know riot and it's like previously
on the [ __ ] show that was the january 6
riot or just the trump administration in
the final days like either way you want
to look at it they are doing a very good
job of saying next week expect this
last week like i think they're even
doing recaps now where they're doing
snippets uh to kind of give you a a
refresher of the you know two to three
hour segment that they that they are in
the hearings to say okay this is what
you missed last week now get ready for
the next reveal the next bombshell and i
mean today was certainly
a you know what we've heard through
rumors or hearsay here in the background
kind of like oh he was doing this or he
was doing that but now
we're actually getting first-hand uh
eyewitness testimony of someone that is
cassidy hutchinson to say yeah in the
room with trump right during the january
sticks because i think that's the most
important part of the testimony today
was just
just
just the fact that we are
that we are seeing exactly what happened
during that time period right when their
siege was laid on the capitol so again
folks do not forget to subscribe here on
youtube to the midas touch youtube
channel also go over to the tony
michaels podcast and subscribe over
there
you can download all of the midas touch
podcast on apple spotify google whether
it be the is touch podcast legal af
maya culpa kremlin file or if you just
want to see i think they have a new one
they have a new podcast it's called the
mighty they're overwhelming every day
every day
i need to i need to see if we can uh
figure out exactly what this is so we
can properly promote it here but i i see
this mighty and
apparently it's it's it seems like this
weekend this weekend was like kind of
the premiere of the mighty yeah so go
check that out go check that out on all
the directories um the mighty um and
again follow follow on youtube because
we're gonna have more of these hearings
and i think they're gonna be more and
more groundbreaking as we go along here
so everyone stay tuned uh to the midas
media network thanks for joining us
today on this tuesday june 28th for the
special
urgent day six i guess it would be
called yeah it's an urgent and boy
emergency you know
the press it did not disappoint it did
not disappoint so thank you and good day
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking